what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos as you guys already know if
you've watched two or more of my labs
and you do not subscribe we have beef
okay beef people a couple announcements
before we start the show the first being
that all super chats will be read over
let's do 20 today
um
all super chats are going towards an 8K
camera that is what we're trying to get
blessing so um yes donate to help us get
the camera on top of that we have two
clips channels the first is just Pearl
eclipse and the second is Pearl daily so
make sure you go subscribe to both our
memberships our members only to our chat
is members only today and if you want to
see our new studio sign up for our 10
tier our third tier is a one-on-one no
our third tier is connecting with me on
social media and our fourth year is a
one-on-one call with me once a month go
follow my Instagram
just.pirlythings and go follow my Tick
Tock just just pearlythings.4 and just
pearly things dot five
um if you want to come on the show DM
Eddie his link is in the description so
today we have a huge panel
um the biggest we've ever had on the
show so you know shout out to you guys
um so why don't we go around everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact and then so we're
gonna start here go around then second
row cool um hi my name is Iman I'm 33
years old and I am single
um I was fun fact
I'm a Pisces Sun Scorpio Moon born and
raised in Kuwait
okay okay awesome my name is zubi I am
36 years old
um interesting fact
I was I grew up in Saudi Arabia a lot of
people know that I don't know how
interesting it is
um but yeah born in England family from
Nigeria
member of the Igbo tribe of Nigeria
um yeah went to an American school for a
while graduated of Oxford University
Computer Science
all right
hi my name's Jody I'm 25 and I'm
currently in a relationship
um fun fact is that I used to have my
own podcast nice
hi my name is denalva I'm 29
relationship status free and
fun fact
I've got a master's degree in U.S
foreign policy
hey you already know man king Richie is
on YouTube make sure you go subscribe to
my channel man don't wait around yeah um
what's it another thing we got just
pearly things make sure you're
subscribed if you're not subscribed yo I
don't know what you're waiting for yeah
and uh fun fact quickly check me out
yeah we can still hold on um fresh and
fair we did a lovely podcast yesterday
with Cheyenne Reynolds yeah um check
that out all that good stuff but yeah
make sure you're subscribed to this
channel yeah and mine yeah don't forget
how old are you big boy I am classified
bro
it's a secret that's not a secret but I
just classic okay okay
19 Jenny 54.
fun facts I grow my own vegetables
okay starting with you guys then go
around
see you hi yeah yeah bigger V from
bigger vtv got my own YouTube channels
check it out shout to just pull and I'm
33 I'm old
are you single or what I'm very single
yo what's up people my name is t I'm 28
uh fun fact
I'm gonna have to keep that one
probably between myself but I'm a man
united fan so any other man united fans
pick up themselves God bless you
what's going on um I'm PGM
um 28 and fun fact I've been connecting
bid since 2019.
that was good
my name is Phil I am 37 fun fact
I don't know if I've been shot twice Wow
Wow
for real on my side and my arm both
times was not my fault
I'm going to ask the question last three
boys are y'all single or what oh sorry
about that yes I'm
yes uh beard gangs got a girl yeah you
said that a bit too no yeah
it's good she's me I'm single so yeah
uh my name's Alexander 27 Bachelor
and interesting fact is I learned
Chinese for three years
you lost her from that point yeah
hey everyone my name is Amber Jade I'm
28 I'm single and a fun fact is that I
do music
[Music]
I like the Clapping I feel like
I didn't even not even initiate that one
uh what about you Poe what's your name
oh you want me to you they know that
okay I'm 25 my name is Pearl
um I'm single and a fun fact is I have
nine siblings
we're Catholic we don't believe in birth
control
okay
um so today's topic is a really fun one
it's modern modern women don't deserve
happiness
she went there
um so my first question is what is a
modern woman to you
um a modern woman is someone who can
balance their work and family life uh
someone who is
willing to grow with time
um yeah that's what a modern woman is
okay go ahead
wow a modern woman is and actually from
the guys I want to know if you date
modern women this is the second question
yeah well
it's it I mean most virtually all women
you know in the western world now
under a certain age are modern women to
various degrees
um I think that modern women are
impacted and influenced whether or not
they classify themselves as such by
feminist ideology
um and a lot of the
trappings of modern society and culture
um some are some adopted all wholesale
some are more resistant but overall it's
influenced and permeated through Society
over the last few decades in a lot of
ways and I'm sure we'll talk about that
okay do you date modern women
yeah I guess okay okay go ahead
um I think modern women is
I agree with what you say
also
modern women are now
based upon female rap culture so a lot
of I get my own [ __ ] love Independent
Women
um I can do what I want and all of this
kind of stuff
um so I think the main key word is like
this sense of independency okay so yeah
a modern woman there's a million sub
categories to that there's the corrupt
there's the stuck in the past and old
tradition and there's the ones that have
evolved
yeah I'll say nothing all right
all right so mother women in my opinion
yeah from the Independent they made
their own money oh I've got BMW I've got
my own house yeah boom so I don't need
no man yeah and then they throw their
box around tell them yeah
yeah the vagina they throw their vagina
around yeah and what they do is they
sleep with certain types of guys yeah in
their prime years and then when they've
collected a lot of baggage and they're
out of their Prime and their value is
dropped they want to get with a good guy
Russell Wilson type and then they think
that their value is still high when it's
low it's dropped significantly rough you
know what I'm saying so so this is what
I think are you saying that women's
value is based on on who they sleep with
no no not necessarily not necessarily
that it's based on a lot of things
there's a lot of people okay like age
like the baggage mental and physical
you've collected
it's my turn
it's my turn still wait wait wait wait I
asked you if you finished and you said
yes so all right cool I appreciate that
anyway so yeah Modern Woman yeah do I
sleep with them yeah I'll sleep with
them but like girlfriend like commitment
it has to be like you know some kind of
Traditional Values there because boy
modern women can be a headache in it
like real talk but anyway that's it okay
Auntie Jenny I think modern women are
women on the age of 30 over independent
influenced by social media
and support brats who can't shut their
legs and use their brains
mud
sound like villains okay
um go ahead what do women now are women
that are trying to complete with
masculine energy feminine energy
they go together a lot someone said it I
don't know who said it said about the
whole rap culture the whole women can do
it by themselves and the whole like you
only start buying a house if you collect
of your if your like credit scores poor
you're not gonna get able to get a
mortgage a lot of women are forgiven
they could go out there but have the
masculine energy collect their souls and
then come back and think a man's good
value them sadly enough a man's not good
value for that so you have to be
yourself you have to be independent to a
degree but not in the case of being a
short chain you're getting a short way
to get where you need to get to okay
go ahead and make sure you put bring the
mic to your mouth yeah there you go in
my opinion I'd say
it's a lot of whoa these modern women
they're trying to be like men
but it's like men and women are
different if you really being honest you
know what I'm saying and then a lot of
people aren't living their raps you get
me they think they're looking at cardi B
they're looking at Jada waders they're
looking at Beyonce's but brother you're
not in that 10 so just you get me
yourself humble yourself and be real so
I just feel like
but I guess we're going to dive into it
proper okay
I agree with you like to a point but
then I think modern women is abroad
statement because you've got different
types of modern women
you got something that are going out
there
working getting their bag by then
they'll be committed at home looking
after their man doing everything you
know what I mean so
it's two types of other women oh I think
it's an approach statement
do you date them
do you date modern Revelations yeah okay
okay go ahead man like you know here's
the mic I have my own are we defining
modern women as uh I'm asking what you
would Define what I would do yeah how
would you describe a modern woman I
don't know because uh like a lot of you
guys say the times have changed right so
if the times have changed then what you
would Define that as is also very
different than what my mom or my grandma
would have been back then they might
have been my mom might have been a
little more Progressive than you know
what you would consider modern what I
we'll consider modern today
um the everyday woman if I'm looking at
numbers from around the globe if I'm not
just looking at my little bubble that
I'm in like in London or somewhere
um yeah modern women are people haven't
changed people think they've changed
because they like Auntie said they're in
um social media bubbles they think that
things are different than they are but
they've never been to cities and
countries where it's very much the same
as it's always been so modern women
Modern Men same thing it really hasn't
changed well I date yeah of course
um
I don't think
that the average person is
caught up with what media and social
media has put out so do I think that
people go like you know everyone's like
you were saying men and women are
different I think most of the world
still agrees with that from where I've
been where I've seen I think they still
agree with that so uh
yeah of course yeah yeah okay easily
Alex
uh the Modern Woman is a walking
contradiction so they are
generally narcissists and they are the
first women in I think probably most of
history that they tend to destroy what
they love and Chase what they hate uh
they have a number of things they want
but generally I think the modern woman
doesn't want to love I think the modern
woman wants to feel more than anything I
have a question for you who hurt you
do you say the same thing when women say
men are trash you said you say the same
thing okay who broke your heart sister
are you gonna mend it do you have a
response to that Alex who hurt me yeah
yeah
maybe it's karma then
[Laughter]
what is the Modern Woman I think there
are different forms of a modern woman
but I think a lot of it now is to do
with money morals go out the window in
replacement for money and I often look
at people and what they're flaunting and
think is basically prostitution like
you're saying you'll do this give this
in return for a bag I don't understand
that like if you're going to have sex
with someone do it because you want to I
don't agree with doing it in favor for
material items but then on the other
side there's also other modern women who
exist coexist alongside them women who
are good women they've also had to
obviously move with the times and become
independent but they're also taking care
of all the other traditional aspects at
the same time that's the type of modern
woman that I rate
okay so next question talking about
happiness now do you think that marriage
slash relationships are about happiness
um I think they're more about compromise
and with compromise comes happiness and
kind of
I guess understanding having that
connection having that empathy having
that chemistry is all ingredients
towards happiness but yeah it's a work
in progress It's a journey that's how I
feel
[Music]
um
a relationship to some degree a marriage
specifically actually no I think that
happiness is a part it's a component and
it's obviously a byproduct of a happy
and healthy marriage but I think if the
primary goal of a marriage is just based
around happiness emotions are fleeting
so if the only thing holding your
marriage or long-term relationship
together is both people feeling happy
all the time exactly then that marriage
is going to fail because it's not a
realistic goal and I think it's actually
a very childish way to go into it I
think if you have a good happy healthy
marriage then of course you will overall
be happy and be content but I don't
think it should be set up with the
intention that that is going to be the
goal all the time or you're going to
fall short of that because no one can be
happy all the time yeah I agree I don't
think the primary goal is happiness
um I think it's more about you you know
how you develop independently and then
how you develop together as a unit
um you're never going to be 100 happy I
mean that's the one person that's going
to annoy the [ __ ] out of you like no one
else that's gonna push your buttons but
how you come back from that is basically
what's going to bring that happiness you
know like you know makeup sex and stuff
like that you know so I don't think yeah
like you said if if you're striving for
100 happiness I just think that's fake
that's a fake marriage so I just think
that's not idealistic at all
to me happiness is peace of mind so a
marriage is for you to be in a
partnership that no matter how difficult
or how amazing things are you always
have that peace of mind if things are
bad you're gonna work together to make
them better if things are happy and good
and positive you enjoy them together but
happiness doesn't necessarily mean you
need to have positive things all the
time it's just how you look at things so
my husband baby support me into feeling
positive about most things even when
things are bad
what's the question
I was thinking
is marriage slash relationships about
happiness because nowadays people don't
even get married it's about Duty okay
you know what I'm saying because
obviously when you get married yeah like
obviously it's basically a business
transaction when you think about it like
people get gassed about love love love
bro like bro love is is not
unconditional about there's conditions
to that bro like everyone has to play
their positions you know what I'm saying
if you mess up whether it's the man or
the woman brother someone's gonna should
hold you accountable like you know what
I'm saying like bro like this is not
what I signed up for yeah then
especially if you have children involved
but there's even a larger amount of Duty
involved do you know what I'm saying a
lot of us we didn't even come from
families where we come from Marriage you
know what I'm saying or like I know me
personally and most of my friends didn't
come from no home where we had our mom
and her dad most of us was just like our
mom you know what I'm saying like so a
lot of us don't even know what it looks
like we've not experienced it so
like not to not to be funny but like
when I hear people's
um like idea of what it is like most of
us don't even really know we're just
we're just saying what we think in it
like but is that really what it is
because
um if you ask people from the 1950s they
probably have something different to say
you know what I'm saying so like that's
just
realistically I'm not married I haven't
been married I don't have kids so I
don't know you know what I'm saying like
I just got an idea of what it may look
like but when I get into it if I ever
get into that yeah it might it might be
something else like you know I mean but
I think more than anything is Duty in it
like you know what I'm saying if you
have that mindset if it's Duty you're
more inclined to stick with it you know
what I'm saying so that's what I think
I just think that when two people get
together
but when they go into marriage I just
believe that
a man can't make you happy you're
supposed to be happy and he's supposed
to make you happier same thing goes
the other way around because a lot of
people go into relationships or marriage
thinking oh well he or she's going to
make me happy
and they're not happy to start with so I
just think in relationships happiness is
a bonus it's something that you grow to
have
but you've got to be happy before you
enter a relationship and then the person
make you happier like me I was always
happy my man makes me happier if I
wasn't with him I'd still be happy but
just not as happy as I am when I'm with
him foreign
so if you're going to a relationship
like she said it's a bonus so they're
added to your bonus you're not going in
there like expecting them to make you
happy you should be happy in yourself
however that person you meet you have to
understand the uncommisables and stuff
you'll compromise on so when you're into
a relationship you have to understand
that I will compromise on this I won't
compromise on that that's the reason you
get into relationship knowing that
they're good they're bads and they're
uglies if you get in there naked and you
go and they're blindsided you're going
to be oh my God I can't believe this
person like that but when you get into a
relationship again my some brother said
it's a it's a financial commitment it's
a partnership commitment it's all these
things mixed in one to get to where you
need to get to and that happiness comes
from yourself but when they're together
and you understand what they like that's
an added bonus to yourself that's my
opinion on it anyway yeah
well just touching up on what he said
and what Auntie said literally like if
you're not happy within yourself
wait it's going to be very hard to make
yourself happy you know what I'm saying
and if you rely on someone else for the
happiness you've already felt so a lot
of people they don't see that a
relationship is they have their self and
then they've got the relationship you
get me so it's like when you come into
relationship you should both be
complimenting yourself in different ways
and you should understand that no one's
perfect you get me some people go
everyone's got flaws but you need to
understand the flaws that you can
tolerate you know what I'm saying
because you can't just be like oh
from the start in the first three months
it was all good everything that I do
it's always always good at the start you
get me but you know delve into stuff you
see two people's colors and stuff like
that you now have to understand that yo
boom this is the floors
this is the good you put that together
that's what makes the person the person
you get you can't pick and choose what
you like from someone and then have an
ideology of someone that's where they
just starts getting into like you're
never going to be happy if you're
chasing happiness it's like [ __ ] also
for the swim but it's like people that
take that mad drugs heroin and they
always say like the first time is the
mad and they chase the hit if you're
going to get Happy from the first time
you but that person and then you're just
chasing the happiness all the time you
ain't ever going to be happy so you just
gotta make sure you're happy from the
start
um for me the main thing really is like
it's more of a conscious effort to make
your partner happy I mean so
there might be things that you don't
want to do but you do it anyway because
you know it's going to make a person you
have happy so
that's the main thing
I
um do not like the word compromise
because compromise means one if not both
members of the party do is not happy
with the agreement I prefer cooperation
right you have to cooperate to get to an
end goal of what you want you know what
I mean so I removed that from it is a
quick little story I had an Uber driver
one time who I he I asked him he was
driving and he was missing his thumb I
said what happened to your thumb just
tell me what happened to your thumb so
we can do this drive because I'm an
[ __ ] and uh he was like oh I got cut
off when I met my wife I said what
happened he said oh dude she was dating
cut my thumb off at a bar fight he's
from Saudi Arabia somewhere I don't
remember because I don't pay attention
where people are from I don't care and
um she got his finger cut off and he was
14 when he met this woman she was 14 the
guy she was dating was 20 uh but you
know R Kelly and so uh it is what it is
and uh he was like 60 at this point and
I said well what did you do he goes you
know we got this thing as a whole thing
eventually long story short she saved my
finger she took my finger you to the
hospital where I was they tried to sew
it back on but where I'm from the
medicine was not where it should be and
I said so how long have you been married
I've been married 50 years and I go how
did you not cheat
he goes what do you mean I go I mean how
did you not cheat or leave like 50 years
is a long time to not put your penis
somewhere else no offense ladies uh I'm
sure it's the same for you but it's a
long time to get along he said oh I
don't compromise my wife we cooperate
and it's my duty is what he said and he
said the other thing is
there's not happiness it's not love
every day I don't love her every day I'm
not happy with her every day but I
respect her every day he goes if you
don't respect the person that you meet
and that you marry and that you're with
forever it'll never work he was like
some days I want to throw her through a
wall because I don't like her I don't
love her she said something she pissed
me off she pressed me and I'm over it he
goes but you know what she's the mother
of my children she's been with me for 50
years she took my finger to the hospital
to try to get its sewn back on I respect
this person he goes so that's why I'm
with it and that's why I'm together with
her I forgot the question but that's all
I had
your question about that like what
was them oh he was I was 27 at that
point that was 10 years ago and he was
almost 60 then yeah so it's an older
it's an older mindset it's an older
mindset where he said I don't compromise
because that doesn't make any sense I
cooperate with her so we can get to an
end goal because that's our duty and I
respect her no matter what she respects
me as well but I respect her but like my
point was like them women of that
generation that's that's different women
bro it's very different it's also a very
different culture than what we're used
to in the west they're the same women
that raised us though it's very true
it's very true but but
yeah wouldn't that be wouldn't that be
our grandparents generation almost
because I don't because it seems like
there's like a change when it's like the
our parents like it seems like our
grandparents because Grandparents were
the ones like Man had side chick across
town she still stayed
my granddad has a whole had two other
whole families yeah is what it is but I
don't I don't like growing up my grandma
was my rock right my anything my mom and
dad told me get out of here like I don't
they weren't the parents that they could
have been no offense you know what they
could have been so the way I look at it
is I look at that older generation and I
go okay respect Duty and cooperation is
the only way that long-term thing can
can possibly work like Auntie was saying
like everybody was just saying the
happiness is fleeting that's not gonna
say like even today like we was all
joking and laughing in there but if
people saw that part they would be like
how are they different now like we're
very calm everybody cool now right he
was talking [ __ ] earlier
we can talk a little more but I'm saying
like even in this moment even in this
room we switched up didn't we everybody
switched up to be um be on camera I got
to be cool so it's like that kind of
that energy so I really respect that
everybody you know yeah I'm not gonna
overturn you go ahead bro you got two
more just quickly
there you go so you know like this is
why it's nice to look at women but look
at the men as well he said the man the
Uber driver said it's about compromise
Iris not compromise it's about
cooperation I respect her so it's a
duality we can never just look at the
Modern Woman to be the one that doesn't
know how to cooperate because the man
the ones that say submissions all of
this type of stuff so ham is that's the
problem well but I think I think the
idea is that if 70 to 80 percent of
women are leaving then like you start
with the 70 to 80 before you look at the
30.
yeah that's great but surely we want the
70 to turn into like the 30s everybody
to get married his wife was a housewife
she did submit I don't know if that's
important well I don't know if that's
what he's saying he said an operation
but they cooperated like how they wanted
their relationship to work so she how
does it get to a point where sometimes
you'd be like sometimes I want to throw
it through a wall 50 years
is that constant submission I don't
think so because challenges in marriage
from these things is respect I think the
idea is though in a long marriage like
at the end of the day someone has to
make the final decision exactly like
like someone has to lead the
relationship incorporation and respect
it doesn't come to a veto well yeah
but there's different ways to do it like
okay if there's a CEO of a company and
he knows that this employee is like
disgruntled when he works this way he
may compromise what he wants to do in
order to make the employee happy at
times but it's still his decision
sucks yeah but I still get my will which
means that the disgruntled person the
one that made the complaint and said
this is not cool CEO actually you're
making the wrong decision the CEO will
line a license okay cool which means
that the lack of submission from the
employee actually made the CEO because
it is his decision and that's what I'm
saying right but there's a way to like
bring up
your your disagreements and like a
submissive way where it's like it's like
you you bring it up politely but you
still know he's making the final
decision not you that then comes down to
respect and not submission but why is
being polite submissive exactly is
respect I I think the idea I'm sorry I
might have misspoke but I'm saying like
like because a lot of girls will come
off very argumentative and they they
just want to like get to their point
across and just like they're frustrated
I'm saying like like you can bring up a
concern but the idea is like I trust you
to make the decision I I think a lot of
I think a lot of women I think a lot of
modern women get hung up on the word
submission
yeah it's it's the word itself can we
correct that to our body gets a bit
confused with submission because it's
not just the girls I'm telling you not
brought that up because the mandem
thinks the mission is [ __ ] shut up your
mind
no that's not the guys that that's the
kind of God
no I think I think the idea last show
was that you were talking about like you
dated the rapper right now
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah he didn't want to give his
government name in the beginning but
wait wait
so I I approached them first he's got
like the tattoos the gold teeth the gold
jewelries wait did you say you
approached him first yeah yeah I spoke
to him oh okay okay
and I was like okay so he fits a certain
stereotype he looks like a certain way
so he may come across you can make a
judgment but actually hearing what he
has had to say and how he has spoken
he's quite balanced he's just a
hardcover but sweet story can I ask can
I ask
is he like a Libra though well yeah yeah
tons of times just getting some [ __ ]
about my horoscope
you're Pisces in it no oh then Gemini
no see but I would be all those things
back in the days
all right guys what is the biggest lie
you've ever told to get laid that's a
good one Vegas
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
on the initial question of whether love
relationships and marriage were based on
happiness yeah uh no it's based on
practicality and you know Offspring Etc
outside of that I have no real
interested in the question though
she doesn't know don't worry
I'll I'll take it I'll take you guys
um I think married you have to actively
get up and say I want this to work like
it's not just going to fall into your
lap you have to look at it like almost a
job like you're going to commit to this
person respect them
take their feelings into consideration
you have to literally get up and
actively work on it every day or it's
not going to work basically
okay so what do you guys think of women
that say never settle
you know I want to hear from the guys
first that means that men are settled
why don't you start I'll start yeah
um they're gonna end up very lonely for
a long time
um it's it's not realistic look the
truth is
everyone there's always some degree of
settling it's a bit it's a little bit of
a weird term like I know what people
mean when they say never settle but if
you were to take that literally nobody
is perfect you're not going to find
anyone who takes absolutely every single
box and never annoys you and doesn't
have little habits and quirks and
personality traits that bother you at
times that's just a real we have this
with our own friendships we have this
with our own families right
um so I think it's good not to settle on
your non-negotiables right if you've got
certain deal breakers or there are
certain red flags and I don't recommend
settling on a massive red flag or
something that just is not going to work
but when it comes to the smaller minor
stuff if someone still has that never
settle mentality then you're never gonna
you're not gonna be happy with anybody
in any relationship for a long period of
time because they're always going to do
certain things that annoy you and
there's going to be stuff you're not
totally happy about so yeah it's like a
polite it's like a polite way of saying
die alone yeah
there's cats sometimes dogs but cats
seem to be the preferred nowadays you've
got only friends as well don't forget
that yeah
that's only going to work for a couple
years
young you'd better be hot
okay but I've invest in cat food
let's play this spots in Petco all of
that bro because at the end of the day
all this never settle and all of this
like bro like you're just gonna be old
on your own drinking wine yeah like
eating ice cream and bro like you're
gonna lose bro
simple like all these girls need to
understand because it's like what I said
earlier yeah a lot of these girls get
older they collect baggage and they
think their value goes up or it stays
the same no it don't as you get older
yeah the guy is on your level especially
if you make a lot of money because of
hypergamy you're going to want to date
up a lot of them guys on your level or
higher are gonna want younger women
broth yeah so understand this thing like
bro like all this never settled thing
everybody settles bro it's a and it's
the same for guys as well like you might
be a guy that oh yeah I just want to go
with big tits and a big bum bro like and
then down the line you see them with a
girl that's flat you know what I'm
saying like like pancakes and fried eggs
like that bro like no but it's real
though like even some certain times you
see rappers like you see rappers you
look at their wife and you think ah like
you're a rapper you're whoever and then
your wife is like kind of playing
because he settled and and bro like Bill
Gates like all these kind of people Mark
Zuckerberg you see their girlfriends
they're not bad [ __ ] like that do you
know what I'm saying so everybody says
but the problem is with a lot of these
girls who make their money and all of
this I'm not going to settle and Target
this guy that makes six figures a year
and or six figures a month yeah bruh
like I'm sorry don't go like that and
there's always new 18 year olds that
come out every [ __ ] Year bro so stop
chatting [ __ ] or you can be on your own
and yeah as I said invest in Pet Food
bro pet stocks you get me they're going
up still nothing some women built up a
delusional mindset because they spend a
lot of their time
banging the one percent of guys that
will bang them anyway because that's
what guy's doing pump and dump it's cool
pump and then they think because they're
banged with these guys in the top one
percent that they should
be able to settle down I have a question
for other guys
have you ever slept with a girl that you
wouldn't be seen in public with
a liar any guy that's nice
have you ever slept with a girl that you
wouldn't be seen in public with multiple
times yeah
[Music]
have you have you ever had a long-term
situationship with a girl you would
never be here
you know why they maintain because they
stay in that that lane light
you don't want to be seen with them and
they do they just come to the crib and
kicks
they're happy to be around high energy
exactly so they're thinking I'm not
gonna get a guy like this in my life I'm
gonna stay around him and smash him I'm
happy to be around him that's good like
you just said people they normally like
it's not the level
you want to bust your knot and go listen
it's a certain thing and this is a a
term is called a human jerk off the
listen I said this to my friend today
maybe but you've been in a situation
where you've been done having sex and
you go to the bathroom and you look at
yourself in the mirror and you go I'm
not coming back here
again what is wrong with you
and then you find yourself back there on
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
right now
you got it you say oh I did you gotta
wait you gotta I'm waiting I'm you're
gonna we're gonna go in a couple more
dates cool I'm gonna go [ __ ] this fat
[ __ ]
and then you get your dick in somebody's
sink like an [ __ ] and you just
washing yourself like why am I and you
talking you know what I'm talking about
you're having this prep talk like I'm
not gonna do it I'm not gonna do this no
more
oh my God
back again it's a term for this it's
called CLS consequential loan of
standards
clarity
um
Bro you've gone to the edge of the
bedroom you just put your hand in your
head in your face
I need help I need Jesus
you guys need to stop
settling
27 27. that's why
I was like if you think I'm about to
settle for you but do you see how fine I
am absolutely not as soon as I hit 30 I
was like who won it
I'm tired
my life rate is
my ability to die
is a lot sooner so I was like well I got
to get this in and I don't have time
to be serious to be very serious it is a
very serious thing where as a as a guy I
always say I wish it was an invention
that would allow men and women to switch
bodies for like 24 hours and you could
understand like the difference
my penis doesn't but you say that's what
I mean so you say self-control
the biology
and you're right there is self-control
but it's to a limit can I tell you a
secret can't compare yourself to a man
and a man can't compare yourself
one at a time
she's been trying to go ahead yeah I've
been patient you've been good this
stream you've been good go ahead go
ahead I learned the rules now
with that number one girls also so do
that but on a more superficial level
they just use the man that is just
somebody that is definitely not my level
but I'm bored and I need lunch so we'll
do that so that goes on both ways and
then let me tell you something about
that as a man if you can practice sexual
discipline I feel like that's one of the
most attractive things you can ever ever
do a woman will look at you differently
and that happened to me I actually I
moved to a guy for the first time ever
because he has sexual discipline and I
thought you're special because that
means that you are not one of them weak
ones that you know the mind works your
body you you
wait what's it why is it weak to you
it's weak because if you are with a
woman and you can't keep it in your past
because you see somewhere with a big bad
to your baby woman you said that guy was
this um had sexual discipline um yeah
which means that one is in a
relationship and even comes to tempt he
says no devil I won't kiss you tonight
in the sense that like what you're so a
man normally hits his prime right like
in his 30s right 32 35 so if if you're
out here saying that your standards
actually got lower when you're supposed
to be in your because you don't hit your
Prime at 32-35 you hit your Prime in
your 20s
exactly so what she's saying is very
different and what you're saying I I
agree with the control aspect I'ma be
honest with you
I don't know how old you are but I'm
going to be very honest with you this
lying is very easy
and if you say something like oh he's
controlling himself I have to be very
I'm being I don't know you and I'm not
trying I'm be honest I'm not trying to
sleep with you so I'm being honest with
you
um I know that sounds [ __ ] up
but I'm being I'm being 100 honest with
you there's a lot of weight you guys do
not hunt
there's a lot of ways to hunt and
there's a lot of ways to get away with
what you want to get away with if you
want to get away with it and that's all
we spend our time doing now he's a very
intelligent brother this [ __ ] is
very smart so he's not on the same
playing field as a lot of guys like he
might have sexual discipline because he
wants to write and do other amazing
things but the average brother that you
run into guy or whoever you want
rappers rappers if they're telling you
I'm going to have discipline and hold in
myself and not have sex with 40 Puerto
Ricans trying to have sex with me all
right you can listen
that's why you're talking about that
baby
I have a question for the guys what's
the longest you've had a situationship
with a girl that you wouldn't be seen in
public with like how long
she's trying to get mine in trouble
they all look disgusted
obviously everyone 's been a [ __ ] but
it's just like why are you lying okay
one person who's like
um
situations you're talking about I feel
like they wouldn't graduate to a
situationship okay they wouldn't even
get to that stage
some of them be capping
I'll be real I'll be real
a couple months a couple months
um what's it uh
not that long man because if the girl's
dead yeah
if the girl's dead yeah like my
motivation is low fam light you know
what I mean like if she says anything
stupid oh yeah what are we bruh
my God my God it's on the tap this is
whenever you're ready it's there for you
exactly yeah
but yeah like don't have side Converse
literally like one two smash like boom
like that's it bro like I'll tell you
one little quick story there was one
girl in uni like boom like my bridging
had a little linkage bought the friend
the friend was a bit chubby you know not
really anyway smashed on the floor in
the kitchen
he's like
trust me that's not even the worst story
but anyway so smashing on the floor yes
my shoes was on breath yes
in the kitchen
um what's it smashed in the toilet as
well and then like um like she was like
messaging me I was just like bro you're
dead bro like what am I gonna do like
bro like like you're gonna bring my
ratings down like my stats is gonna
reduce significantly so but like I I
think if a girl's dead yeah at most like
a beat for that night like one night
special and then really and Judy what
are we gonna do after that nothing in it
like maybe maybe honestly probably three
three smashes and then after that like
bro like you're gonna catch feedings or
something stupid because she cooked for
you though probably no no no
I don't do nothing
no but the thing is
but the thing is while I'm smashing the
dead thing I'm still patting in other
things that I actually like that makes
sense that makes sense I've got projects
bro
so you could say Investments
like get me four it's not like my
selling teams to these girls saying that
you're always nice
did she ever like graduate into a
bedroom or that no no no no no no no
let's talk to the the women okay so
question
um
I have two questions so I'm gonna ask
both at the same time okay the first
have you ever gone on a date with a guy
that you did not find attractive yeah
because you wanted a free meal yeah and
the second one is have you ever had a
friend that was the whale in this
situation that they're all describing
and did you tell her the truth about
what was going on okay uh first question
um I may have been out with a guy that I
didn't find attractive initially but it
wasn't for the meal
um basically like I think that like
looks aren't everything in a
relationship if someone has personality
Integrity like has a brain
then that could take you places you
don't necessarily have to look like a
hundred million dollars for me to kind
of like there's other there's other
factors other ingredients that would
make a man
my type
um in terms of the second question
um I would say no because all my girls
are paying like nah there's never been a
situation
that's my best friend all your girls are
paying okay beautiful all my friends
yeah I mean your friend can be pretty
but she could still punch out of her
leaves yeah exactly like she could be a
solid seven punching a ten but my
friends are smarter than that they would
never put themselves in a situation
where like they're just kind of like
okay a hole I'm sorry like no I disagree
single I disagree I've gone out with a
guy yeah just four mil I mean the guy I
knew what his intentions were but for me
it was never going past
friendship because I wasn't attracted to
him and you just didn't Tickle My Fancy
I mean you were short you was like
nearly just a bit taller than me
it's not wearing heels and I'm and I'm
like a skyscraper over here
and yeah I went out for a meal I was
like you know what he was a persistent
guy as well he kept on like responding
to my stories and stuff like that so I
was like you know what that's it
it's really easy to swipe off
that's persistent you thought yeah let
me use man for a female because I just
want to eat yeah after work that's deep
fair enough
thoughts
guys one at a time it wasn't a waste of
time because for me like I said I never
saw it past anything being a friendship
you're a cool guy but me and you will
never ever did you express that to him
like we are not going anywhere past a
friendship yeah we can go out and eat no
don't
you let him believe that okay boom
There's an opportunity there's a chance
but in your head you know there is no
chance bro like you're not going
anywhere with me yeah yeah I didn't so
basically use them yeah I did oh okay
I like the honesty I'm not I'm not gonna
die yes hello can we admit that like the
state of being transactional because the
man will take on loads of dates these
fancy restaurants to smash and this is
why I say like as a man you have to set
your standards like some guys in the
beginning they'll take them to The Shard
yeah you can't you can't blame a woman
after that to be expecting fancy one and
dining and stuff like that you've got a
you've got a you know feel it out first
build it up a bit a bit a bit and then
see if she's actually you know worth it
oh my God a lot of men are simps in it
a lot of men forget that what a woman's
personality is like will make me take
her to The Shard I personally I don't
take girls on dates unless I know
they're serious on my girlfriend level
but these Sims they see your pretty face
your bum your breasts whatever it is I
don't know it is and I'm not saying you
ain't got it but I'm trying to say men
in general and they'll take you to these
places to try to have a transactional
experience and try smash you yeah and
now for you you're looking at the
experience in itself in the general
right yeah so even though you don't rate
him you don't seem in need potential
you're saying he's some free meal right
yep so I think it's a fake though
I'm gonna ask you a question did you see
that guy ever again after that
um
I did I don't want to bait out how I saw
it how I saw him but he basically came
and gave me like a birthday present
after that
he bought you food you enjoyed it you
went home no kiss no hug no nothing yeah
maybe the church did he get it did he
get a side hug at least
but yeah anyway so what was the question
again
um the first one was have you ever taken
a date from a guy you don't find
attractive and the second one was
um has your friend ever been in a
situation that they were describing and
what did you tell her oh yeah I also
wanted to mention as well based upon
what you said because you said you don't
go out with guys you go out with guys
based on their personality but the first
thing you see you have a guy with
anybody is their looks yeah so the looks
is what's going to attract you your
personality comes along with it after
that lips and stuff yeah so you wouldn't
talk to a guy that does it is not
aesthetically pleasing to you and you
wouldn't know that he's a good guy if if
he wasn't aesthetically pleasing just
because
he's aesthetically pleasing doesn't make
him a good guy
why I miss my mind another okay why were
you accept a date with a guy you don't
find attractive yeah maybe because
because to me it's like if you don't
find him attractive in the beginning
that's what you're supposed to fight
maybe I found them attractive based on
our conversation that we had maybe I
found him attractive based on his warmth
you wouldn't give him the time today
and then no I'm just talking about let's
because more time when you see pretty
girls with ugly guys they've got money
if they've got something something of
value to them right so obviously right
right now let's talk about money because
more time that's what girls go for right
and then when you start going out with
him over time you start thinking oh do
you know what he's actually all right
like he's got some substance to him he
can hold conversations
and as for the whale question there's
always an ugly person
ugly girl in the group no matter how
pretty the group is there's always an
ugly girl have I ever told my whale
friends Maybe not maybe I should but at
the same time those friends deal with in
their league they know they're not the
best so they go for like ugly guys so
women always try a day up they never
date down never tell me something tell
them
sorry
I was gonna say well young women need to
do if I was a man
and I took a woman on a date
and fed her I spent my hard-earned money
and not even get the potential of a
relationship at the end of it I'm gonna
be totally pissed off yep because that's
like false advertising I think that when
you go on dates from the time you accept
or you say excuse me but I'm only dating
with the attention
of having a relationship that's what I'm
dating like to vet people
but if you know that instantly you're
not attracted to him
do me a favor just say no say no sorry I
don't see you like that I just see you
as a friend
because otherwise you're just building
them up to fail him and most of the time
it's all the ugly men they're the most
loyal ones out there of course and
they're wimpy when the women treat them
like this
they just get in themselves and those
are the ones that will go at home
and watch corn and jerk off and then get
fed up with women because of how women
treat them and I'd listen to all these
men earlier that's why I was so quiet
listen to you about your box you know
the box I'm learning all these new
things
there was another one but I can't I
can't remember
but the women I know there's loads of
women listening to this
the way men were talking about treating
the women to me it was like
cheap these are the you know no value no
whatever
if you know that this is what the men
think of you and the men know you know
that the men want a woman a woman with
low body count
shut your legs simple don't have no sex
because all the women are going out
there the mother women are going out
there looking for all these
handsome men with money and then they're
going to sleep above all of them
that's how they that's how they vet they
don't vet my conversation anymore they
vet with their vagina
are you not supposed to remember your
vaginas you're supposed to talk to them
and that's what we're supposed to do and
that's what women are doing now and then
they're complaining that the men don't
want them and the men are saying oh I
don't want a woman with high body can
it's just simple
if the men don't want women with a high
body count and the women want certain
type of men if women decided you know
what I'm gonna shut my legs and only
open it with the intention of a
relationship then the men will get what
they want and so the women but the ugly
men that usually are turning down
I guarantee that they'd be more loyal
and they'd be the ones that will stick
with you forever then these ones that
have got the money that all flash that
the women are actually going for
because nobody looks at the ugly people
and also I mean I was saying about ugly
women yeah
nobody
but I wouldn't go and nothing is when
you're dating you're supposed to be
dating with attention of looking for a
husband not dating attention of looking
you know I do sex exactly if you want
sex nowadays I see and the most that
makes it worse the women are going out
there having loads of sex and then you
go to their house and they've got loads
of rabbits in there and Rosie and
as far as I'm concerned
keep your toys and forget about the boys
I'm not trying to teach you nothing
um for a wife I don't give a goddamn
like I'm not going to this to be like oh
you don't know how to [ __ ] like are you
serious get your body count up I agree
with you do you want like a do you want
to learn yourself the problem that I
that I've run into a couple times
different different topic but the
problem I've run into a couple times is
you don't even know how to please
yourself like you don't know what you
like so I'm doing my thing and it's like
I don't know like I'm trying to learn
what you like and if you tell me like oh
you know TR you know Terrell used to do
this cool I'll do what Terrell used to
do and improve on it oh wow but I'm not
one of these dudes who's like oh like
let me show you what it is because it's
like vagina is a slow snow so so you're
cool with like girl raising your kids
that you slept with 50 dudes I don't
care about that 50.
let me tell you let me tell you why I
don't care about it because I've never
ever including like anybody that I know
I don't know I've never had someone be
honest about their body count like I
don't like a woman might thank you a
woman might tell me I've only had 10
dudes you full of [ __ ] like you got
[ __ ] too because the only reason why
is because I know how easy I got it in
my game ain't that damn strong
it's not to say it don't make you lose
it don't make you know ho it don't make
you none of that it just means you know
what you like and what you want 50 is a
lot
okay
but like if you like oh you I'm 37 you
37 you say I [ __ ] 20 guys that's not
bad that's like because because I've
done
I'm surprised my penis is still attached
to my body like just on your point yeah
you want to experience right but aren't
you the man to teach her no I don't know
no I'm lazy
I just eat [ __ ] and move on
He-Man T is looking for you Iman yeah so
how did you that guy you said that you
want to touch you at the start how did
you get to that point to speak to him to
then go on a date his conversation
literally I found him very intriguing he
was a like he was fresh like last time
you messaged you not from the first time
he messaged like it was a consecutive
period of time where we were speaking
and I found him as an interesting person
and that's how it kind of
I went on a date with him okay
um and also like attraction comes with
time like you get to know a person more
and if they've got a good personality
then they become more and more if they
meet you on the street or was it I think
no I was by a friend okay
that don't count because yeah
if it's a guy on the street as a
complete stranger there's no there's no
CV resume nothing like and he's five
foot three and looks like Shrek and then
he's like oh my God you're so you're so
gorgeous you're gonna be like uh like
like this you're not going to find out
if he's got a great character you're not
gonna care bro that's not that's the
that's the truth about it I'm just not
the type of person that would be
approached on the street and just be
okay with going on a date with you it
doesn't work for me like that okay but
you get what you get the point I'm
making that like that guy that you're
talking about who was unattractive that
you gave a chance to there was there was
a middle man do you get what I'm saying
there was someone that verse
and that gave him the lies that gave the
license for you to even get to know him
but if it was a complete stranger you
like like you met me today and you
thought oh this guy's ugly in the corner
like and I was like oh what's your
Instagram you'd be like I wouldn't ugh
sorry like me intrigue me yeah would you
not sorry
I'm gonna give her a chance
you've been so good
because a lot of people sound trying to
stay in my zone but I'll tell you
something I I do things a bit
differently I don't go on dates I go on
meetings that means that
before sexual there's a person which
means that if you keep looking at
somebody be like oh my attracted in my
mind this you may sound the actual value
because that man the same way it could
be your husband it could be your best
friend it could be a business partner it
could be somebody so once you decline or
accept based on looks you'll screwing
yourself number one number two sometimes
as well the looks don't really matter
the person is really lovely you can do
it even out of like being a good person
you're kind you want to take me out why
am I saying no for no reason I'll go
with you but then you will know for sure
you're not for me I'll let you know your
friend zone Brother Zone family Zone
whatever Zone I need to put you in it's
very easy you create boundaries so you
can do whatever you want boundaries
create freedom and then lastly what was
the last question is do you want dates
oh the the the friend okay go ahead I'm
a very honest person when my girls come
to me and they start telling me about
the man first how did he approach you
what did he say what did you say how did
it go okay he's just [ __ ] you please
stop telling me about feelings and
that's the first thing and that's
whether you're pretty or whether you're
well
honesty
so a quick one for you like let's boil
it down to ruin this here yeah you got
eyes right so are you gonna sell because
the guy is not good looking so you're
settling basically you're basically
saying is it settling or is that you're
I'm going on meetings no but we look at
a relationship you have to be with
someone when you want to tear their
clothes off and you've got personality
match right am I being wrong someone
correct me wrong I think that's more for
men you know really no but yeah
I must be a man then woman you must be a
man whoever that is
we could be
if I could be on the airplane but you
know no no you look at you like yo yo we
need to go to the bathroom yeah but why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you want that
as a woman
for example we're not anyone anyone in
this room is not mind Readers first
thing we see is looks what makes us know
their personality beyond that right yeah
don't be so sure baby oh so your mind
reading yeah it's not you don't need to
be a mind reader you have to be a body
language read and you need to look
people in the eyes and question
everything that they say first you
always know if you think whilst people
speaking to you'll always be ahead of
the game you have to play a game because
this is Art of Seduction I've been
reading that book and it's taught me a
lot so love is a game
listen I sit here and I can have a
conversation with anyone to ask you
about three questions to make you be
like oh you know she's kind of nice
she's quite interesting no matter what
your first impression of me was one of
them will be where are you from because
it shows that I'm kind of showing any
sort of interest in you I can do
whatever I want with you if I've got a
look I'm a woman I ask you the right
questions you think she's generally
interested men like girls that are also
interested because they make them seem
easier so answer my question is Love
Again
love because the way you are subscribing
it's all time listen love is one of
those things that there's an attraction
but then you need to secure the deal
securing the deal is the game what's the
deal the deal is making sure that the
person is aware that you love them and
you love me therefore we're going to
create something and ask your questions
persuasion yo yo yo you you've got all
this Insight in this thing yeah are you
are you currently winning do you know
why why I'm winning because all the
wrong ones is falling off like so you
have all this knowledge you know every
strategy you know exactly what to do
look in the eyes and all of that Michael
I made you smile so much today
do you think you're winning I am winning
because realistically okay I'm not gonna
say really in my opinion are you single
and let me tell you something yes
we need do I win because I have to be in
a relationship the reason why I'm not in
a relationship is out of choice
let me let me ask you you said the
reason you're not in a relationship is
out of choice yeah so if you found the
perfect guy right now would you date him
yeah I'm actually working on something
okay okay so wouldn't you say that the
guys you want then don't want you no
it's not that they don't want me
let me tell you something like I said to
you already for you to create a
relationship it takes to detangle you
people at this you don't trust somebody
like that you have to test out you need
to make sure so what you do that's when
the game and the little dance is there
that's where the seduction play comes in
so all I'm saying is I'm winning because
every single time I get to suss out who
I want and who I don't want so I say I
don't want you but you are nice and
you're still interested if I want to do
like this tomorrow I can if I want to
open my legs and secure it quicker I can
but I don't want to so I'll take my time
it's better challenging can I can I just
say trust is not repetition wow trust is
benefit of the doubt repetition is that
you come and you turn your light on and
the light works when you turn your light
on it don't work a million things go
through your head is it the light bulb
that I pay the bill am I having a power
shortage is the power out that's
repetition that's not a way to trust
somebody because the second they deviate
from that repetition that you are used
to you no longer trust that person in
it's hard and or impossible to get that
trust back trust is benefited
something that I said are you just
making a point both
because you said you said it's a game
it's do we trust each other do we go to
this I will put you through this
multiple things to see if I trust you
that's fine to do but what I'm telling
you is that's again goes back to and
again I'm telling you this because I'm
not trying to [ __ ] you I'm telling you
the truth that is very easy to
manipulate from a man's point of view I
can make you think that what I'm doing
in my actions all the time are
trustworthy easy
but but what I'm saying to you I'm not
saying that you're wrong but what I'm
saying to you is benefit of the doubt
will work much better in this any
situation because the benefit of the
doubt is I'm not looking through your
phone because I [ __ ] you raw what's the
point of looking through your phone if I
don't trust you so let me tell you
something quickly
go go
what's the question I guess okay I don't
even remember
every lunch
so you have every pretty girl has come
on I'm ugly then what are you trying to
say that I'm ugly who's ugly who said
he's ugly
look at your skin you said every pretty
woman
I've never been on a free lunch you're
called Auntie for a reason
they're going
sister I apologize
um
I haven't gone out to get free food I've
gone out with somebody that I had a
friendship with that I didn't find
attractive but we was getting on so well
and I thought can I can this go anywhere
and then it confirms 100 no like there's
no attraction for me I know some women
can or some men might be able to wear
that I cannot lie that that date there
confirmed it and I was honest and I said
no because we was friends anyway it was
kind of like here I think he was a bit
Latin word but he didn't express that to
me nobody appreciated your honesty but
um for me personally I have to be very
attracted or it's not going to work like
it's just not gonna work what was the
things about him that like made you
unattracted to him what was it about him
that he didn't like like physically just
the way he looks
myself he's not ugly he's just not my
like I didn't feel like yeah like it
wasn't that it was just so it was just
his face really it's just everything
like the Justice Just build everything I
don't really okay obviously someone
can't be shorter than but I'm not like
if someone's a little bit taller than me
that don't bother me so a man don't need
to be told I know a lot of girls are
like no he has to be too I don't really
care about it so can I ask you a
question If he if he was blind and you
went on a date yeah that made him your
perfect man then if he's blind if he was
blind yeah okay
I don't understand
she was blind sorry yeah she was blind
if I was blind and you went on that date
with him was I blind from birth Yeah
well yeah I wouldn't really know I
wouldn't know about it what I'm trying
to say is that by the way he sounded in
the conversation because you were
friends and everything yeah then it
would have been perfect but my eyes
worked so it couldn't work
so what is what is I need physical
attractions
what is this thing with like people
acting surprised that like women like
physically attracted it makes no sense
and the fact that you guys seem to over
emphasize one thing so women for
attraction and sexual attraction for
women is quite complex right women are
very hard to please they need atmosphere
they need a good conversation they need
good looks they need a good frame they
need Charisma level of status they need
all these things this is why
unattractive guys can constantly win as
you've seen in real life so why do we
come on these conversations and pretend
that like it's only because of looks and
like you're shallow for doing this and
that when it's like well obviously she
gave him an opportunity to show these
other characteristics and most of the
time will fail because women are complex
right most guys don't have those other
questions because they're not obvious
so that's one thing I would say I think
on this matter I think is actually kind
of a good thing so I I haven't had much
experience with these kind of things
like paying for dinners and not getting
like you know smashing or whatever but
when I no no
I will tell you one thing my experience
of that was in uni first year I hit the
clubs and you know I hit the bar and you
know I watched all these American Pie
movies so I thought it was like yeah you
see someone cute you say hey can I get
you a drink try and have a chat in this
crowded busy stinky Club when you can't
hear each other and that's how it worked
in it so so this girl made eye contact
do you want to get a drink queued up
like 10 minutes got her this drink well
seven pound fifty it still hurt I was I
was in Union I was like wrong
I was like that was the dumbest thing
I've ever done that makes no sense so
you know when people when grown men are
like oh I took her out for dinner she
didn't smash it's like bro you could
have bought like a Twix or like a vodka
and figure that out but you didn't have
to do all that quick question for you to
so what for you you only would you only
go out on a date with someone that you
saw as a potential rather than just
someone you wanted to have fun with
but I think if I find someone attractive
and she acts right then you know we will
meet up and do something but I I I
refuse to take anyone out or do anything
like that first I don't really pay for
those I don't I don't believe in that
it's like why do you believe in it it's
2022 bro what equal right and and if you
try it I will set up that conversation
from the start I'd be like all right so
what do you think about this oh it's
crazy and then when we're having dinner
and you're like looking at the bill I'd
be like oh are you so you're not you're
not yeah
just before this podcast yeah I met up
with a friend and um like basically went
out for drinks yet if the girl yeah she
likes you she will offer to pay for a
round
if she doesn't offer she's not even well
like you go to the bar she's just
looking at her phone but she don't
really like you she don't really rate
you like that and if you want to steal
the deal and she offers you say no baby
I got you oh can I just disagree
the friend that introduce you to the man
you went on a date with with male or
female friend it was actually a meal
he read the room wrong
if it was a male thinking about it if it
was a male I think it would have worked
with effort and compromise I think it
would have worked I personally think
that you missed out I mean personally
like we we went into it we got into a
relationship okay oh that's all right
that's a relationship and we were
together for like two three years okay
no because what I'm saying is that women
lie to women
and if you'd been that day with your
checklist um
you know it wouldn't have worked no I
would I've I've been a date recommended
by a female and they always have other
issues so if it's a female don't trust
her
don't trust her at all and that's all
the thing that was going through my
brain is
I wonder if it was a female that
introduced you a male because if it's a
matter and that's what we need to do
stop vetting with your vagina and that's
your friends your male friends to vet
their men for you
even if it's the elders your brothers
your uncle schools other male friends
and you will find that you find better
men if you allow your men friends to vet
them forward because they know the truth
don't forget boys
um I was thinking what if we had someone
in this room pick who would be a good
person to date out of the people on the
piano
your sister okay your sister was here
okay okay who on the panel would you let
your sister date what out of the dudes I
thought you meant who would I pick up
dude to your sister's here first of all
everything she said is what I'm trying
to say is literally what I was trying to
express is like I'm being honest with
you as a dude I'm gonna tell you the
truth I tell my sister I tell them the
truth
this is what he's doing this is why he's
doing it so who would I do yeah so who
who so yeah no go around like yes or no
to your sister dating though
uh dating like a relationship a
relationship like like she he she goes
on and I said I went on a date with this
guy what do you think of him yes
yes no yes what about TV yes and but for
reasons not because he's not a good dude
and not because he's not a good guy he's
not has nothing to do with that it has
to do with they are me
right I know where they are I know where
they've been I know what their mindset
is I know where he is I've had the
private conversation with him I know
exactly where he is this brother grows
beards he's got a very good mindset his
brother's looking for something
righteous so I get it zubi as well
uh me and zubi about to go do Joe Rogan
he only know it now
so zubi I know but I there's a reason is
because I also I'm looking at not that I
care about my sisters like deeply I do
but I know them and their type and I
know
what their what they would say yes and
no to and how they would treat and what
they and who could handle that
that's what that is I also wouldn't put
them in a situation where I might this
month that's my sister bro like I'm
sorry yeah oh I want to say someone
okay okay
okay
yes yes definitely no definitely no and
I'd need to bet you okay yeah
okay okay so I'm gonna change the topic
a little bit so
um
with modern women the epidemic is that
even with birth control
we're getting more abortions than ever
does if a girl gets an abortion does
that take her out of the wife category
100 Why million percent
complete moral misalignment okay
it's a fetus no I'm very very strongly
pro-life so you tell me why no
absolutely not tell you why yeah yeah
why a woman who can happily kill her own
child
when she was a victim of grape
that's less than that's fewer than one
percent I don't know fewer than one
person let's talk about the 99 yeah yeah
why is it why is it that whenever a dude
makes a point we always got to bring up
the exception as well it's not even a
common exception that's quite a common
thing for women to experience no no it's
not no it's not well but it's not common
it's great it's not great it's not
necessarily a pregnancy through great
but grape in general is no it's not no
that's my job I deal with them clients
every single day so what's the
percentage looking like
I think that's because that's your job
that's your job so you get to see them a
concentration but if you look in the
whole of the UK yeah you see that but if
you're a minority everyone if you're
looking at it no I'm saying like if you
if you look at Stats that's not true
it's not the majority of women it's
actually a very small percentage because
otherwise we're just going off of he
said she said and she can say anything
if it was a majority then most of it I'm
not saying the majority of women have
experienced grape I'm saying there's
quite a large percentage of women that
have experienced it but no not
not statistically it's not it's not the
large majority well it's a mind it's a
very small minority I'm not gonna lie to
you yet just being super real and
understanding about the life that we're
trying to live now and what like the
status of the world is
I mean as long as you're willing to deal
with the consequences of your choices my
friend save yourself and save your child
because sometimes you get into an
accident with somebody that is
definitely not the man that you need to
be having a child with and you're
definitely not in the right space of
mine so instead of you putting like a
child into your chaotic well just you
know be more responsible he's not kill
it but like before he gets to a stage
where it's like super gone like you at
the at the end of the day now you got
the option of like taking a little bit
of control if that puts bad energy into
the universe deal with the consequences
but at the end of the day you'd rather
do that than to like bring a traumatized
child into the world I actually have a
question do you think that uh poor kids
are less valuable than rich kids because
you know when you think about it we're
all rich because most people in all of
human history have been even poor people
are richer than most people were in all
of history I would say that that's
definitely not true because I I'm
African I know what what like what it
means to be poor and still be be happy
to be privileged and blessed what I do
mean is for example there are people
that are just not in the in the best
state of mind or even in a relationship
that could be supportive of bringing a
healthy citizen into this world and then
if people don't have this sort of
control it gets to a stage where
everybody's going to be messed up
because their parents are making
mistakes at the end of the day instead
of us judging abortions let's just first
deal with sexual education sexual
discipline and then we can avoid
abortions other than that
we're talking about taking a human life
here okay no we're talking about we're
taking control of something that
actually hasn't got to that stage yet it
depends on how you feel about it but
it's not feelings you're if literally
take you can sugarcoat it how you want
it's the taking of an innocent human
life
to an extent it depends
okay okay you can have your feelings
about it I'm just saying that's
literally what it is let's move away
from euphemisms and feelings that is
what it is all right can I just say
something
to both women together
when I first came to show remember I
said to you there's not a situation that
I haven't experienced remember I said
that churches ago now I was in a
relationship I was young I was 16 and I
wouldn't say I got put into relationship
a very abusive relationship and I had a
child through grape
I was 17. I was on the pill
so 17 I couldn't say I had loads of
money because I was still living at home
and as far as I'm concerned I had my
child
at 17 years old no money and I worked
and I kept my child and when everybody
keeps on talking about grape and abuse
yes Pearl I did report it right had it
down in Junctions and everything I still
got my child
everybody was against it because in
those days I bought shame on the Family
but nobody knew why I had my child
and to this day I've still got one child
because I was only able to have one
child and because I don't believe in
abortion
and I was a Foster carer and I fostered
and looked after 10 children as a single
parent
and I don't care how poor you are I
don't care what situation you're in
unless your life is in danger I still
don't believe in abortion can I say
something and I was on the pill uh
there's there's a thing there's certain
people there's it's just like a luck of
the draw there are there's people that
are extremely blessed that the situation
and they're actually blessed with a with
a mother that will take care of you from
whatever situation make you be a
wholesome human being and show you all
the Love on the flip side there are
people that then go on to abuse their
children because they don't know any
better they're people that go to neglect
their children because they're not in a
supportive relationship or because they
can't handle it if you realize
did you hear what I said I said I was a
foster carer I was a Foster carer and I
fostered 10 children those children
you're talking about and they had better
lives for it because
and I only foster children primary
school age so I had children that have
been abused physically and sexually at
that age so nobody can't give me the
excuse use I mean that's your opinion
I'm giving you my experience so as far
as I'm concerned if the care system that
allows these women to have the children
that allows these women to have
abortions they also allow these children
to have that allow these women to have
the children and hand them over to
responsible people that will look after
and nurture and care for those children
rather than murder them because people
murder their children too often and then
those who don't get murdered I look
after I look after I raise I nurture and
I look after them and I'm sure there's
there's African children indian children
white children out there that I've
fostered that have been to University
being models and having good stable
lives because of me so I'd rather even
at my age now
I would rather look after somebody
else's child I've looked after children
that have been sexually abused at two
and three years old I have had them and
I'd rather have them knowing that I
looked after them
then they got murdered and as far as I'm
concerned it's not the it's not these
children it's Society
and if the people are messed up people
are out there having sexual lessons and
in school they don't teach them
parenting lessons skills like cooking
skills managing money and that's what
the people need because there's no
poverty I'm going to be the one to say
there's no poverty in England England
you get paid to have children it's the
parents and the people that have the
money that are mismanaging it so rather
than go out there and say oh this is a
poor person this look at what they're
doing manage their money because I
guarantee you those children
who come from those households look the
parents are smoking
they can afford to smoke they can smoke
a full smart screen TV they can afford
jewelry the children have got all the
latest phones and tablets and everything
but yet they're going to say there's
poverty because they have no food they
have no clothes it's not to do with the
government it's to do with them managing
their money so as far as I'm concerned
no child deserves to be killed unless
the mother's gonna die may I say
something auntie I appreciate what
you're saying it's a very touchy topic
because obviously it's it's sensitive I
believe that children to me are one of
the purest things in the world and if it
gets to a stage where actually you have
a choice either terminate this life
right here right now the energy is still
in the world the energy still exists but
terminated now instead of a lot of
playing with chance of letting a child
go into the system and become an
extremely wounded human being I'd rather
do the other because you'll go to a
better place the same way I believe in
euthanasia is the same way I believe in
abortion oh gosh obviously that's
different because
I don't believe in any funnel murder so
that's why we're always going to differ
that's why we're always going to agree
right because anyway
I want to hear what the rest of what you
had to say zooby I didn't hear your
opinion yeah finish your opinion yeah
well like we wouldn't work right so
that's the answer to the question very
clearly that's a complete moral message
I said maybe to you
it's a complete moral misalignment right
like everything you've just said there
that's freaking horrifying can I ask and
I'm not disagreeing with you zubi can I
ask why you don't support killing people
yeah no well I used to be a [ __ ] so I'm
with you but can I support why you don't
uh can I can I I just want to know I
don't get to talk to people that have
always varying different opinions all
the time because we live in Echo
chambers of course so I'm very
interested and I'm not that I disagree
I'm very interested in why you don't
believe in abortion outside of the to
killing people because we kill people
with tons of other things but what is
the thing about abortion very simple I
think it I think it is wrong to
intentionally terminate an innocent
human life yeah period that's it
I think it's a crime to corruption
I would never been able to have another
child again and I would have been
childless
and I was on the pill but I would have
never had a child again and you know
what when I got pregnant I actually told
I had a old Aunt well she was a you know
like Auntie and I went to her and I said
to her two people I told first my
stepdad
and that aren't and I went to her and I
said
explain to us that I'm pregnant and she
sat me down and she said and this is in
the old days and she said Jennifer she
said I've been seeing this married man
for years
and you know like when you get them
women back in the day that they would
that was the woman and he and she said
and I got I got pregnant she goes and he
said to me it's either me
or the child
and this man was everything to where her
world took her out they went places and
she said I decided to choose my child
and she said to me when I was having the
child there were complications and she
said I'll never be able to have another
child
and she's only got one son she goes we
have your child and exactly what
happened to what happened to me and I
got the one child
well I'm I'm not gonna lie I can
sympathize when I speak before I want
sympathy I I I I O2 was in a very
complicated relationship I put it as
that and I was in that same situation
and I just determinate you know why
because I said listen I would rather
take that risk than to create do that
for my child because this person is
definitely not going to be a good father
to my child I already vetted the
situation and if he gets to a point
where I can't have any children I'll do
an alternative I Will Bless other souls
and give my love and my energy to
somebody that is not even my child
regardless of whatever happens whether I
can have children or not I'll still
bless people I'll still give love I will
still be able to be a mother even if
biologically that was my not my Meant To
Be My Destiny that's it you can always
find alternatives to things but one
thing that I believe that we should do
is ensure that whatever energy we bring
to or whatever children we're raising
we're going to put them in a situation
where they can be better human beings
otherwise Society is going to to
whatever that's why the situation is now
what they are in England it's very easy
like for people to have children when
they're teenagers look at how everybody
is acting now it's very easy because the
majority of abortions are not from
teenagers No in fact it's actually from
women no and what I'm saying is in the
UK I think the UK is actually the
country in Europe that has the highest
rate of teenage pregnancy and you can
see actually how that's affecting
Society there needs to be a certain way
of controlling this type of of I would
say unhealed traumatized kind of
DNA to keep passing on if you're not
ready to have a child and you can
recognize that you have a choice to
either make the situations worse for you
and affect an innocent child or take the
chance now and make it better it means
you don't have kids again save somebody
else's child go faster go adopt there's
too many people that needing your love
why don't you give it up for adoption
because giving it up for adoption you
put in your child in a situation where
actually you can follow either side of
Statistics either going to be with an
angel person or you're going to be with
the devil that's going to physically
abuse you sexually abuse you why does
your mind always go to like the worst
possible like no no but I'm saying like
like straight I could think of many
situations where adoption worked out
really well and like my mom got pregnant
when she was 17 and she she could have
thought you know my life was over and
she gave that kid up for adoption he
just got married he has a kid now he
grew up with a completely different
family yeah and well fortunately for you
see the good unfortunately on my side
where actually because I I'm even for my
demographic I come from what I see and
what is actually a lot of what I feel
like is the masses most of the people
that I know that in those situations
come from very hard um stories and
backgrounds and when they speak to me I
can see how damaged they are and how
much pain they still feel now because
not everybody's even equipped to learn
how to heal themselves so it's either
we're going to create this but they're
alive but they're alive but they're
still suffering and this is the thing
right for example I'll give you an
example one of my my friend my sister
she has a friend she her parents abused
her her stepdad sexually abused that she
was on drugs she was 16 and actually she
had an accident and she died and the
friends were all very upset they all
really really sad and they cried and
everything but amongst them they said
you know what actually I feel like she's
in a better place because this world was
not treating her right her situation was
making him more depressed and people are
living by suffering they're not living
to live wait I think it's just quickly
is are you religious I'm spiritual
spiritual there I think that's a big
part of it I think what's happening now
is
because I'm I'm spiritual I'm I don't
know what the [ __ ] I am but I'm not
saying that it is what I'm saying is I
think a big part of it is a lot of times
like I have I I don't believe in
abortion but I do not also think that I
have the right to tell a woman what to
do with her body so so what I think not
that you guys are this but I think that
I think a big part of it is that you a
lot of times I have aunts and people who
are very religious life is suffering to
them that's what it is one of the the
things and I think what you're arguing
no offense to you or anybody I think is
very different than what she's saying I
think it's a very two different points I
agree with zooby I agree with Auntie for
the most part uh both of you guys and I
also agree with you like I just said but
I think what you're getting at is from
your personal experience in life and
what you've been through and how you
came out of that experience versus
auntie in in
um zubi and pearl are coming from a
different Pearl's talking about she had
a relative who was a sibling who was
raised in a wonderful world because they
were adopted I think you're coming from
your personal experiences of what you've
seen
yeah of course but that's life yeah I
have any perspective of experience I'm
saying from her I'm saying not you I'm
just saying in general I don't I don't
think it's a religion this thing no it's
not a religious thing I'm just saying in
my head I go I just want to know if she
would say she was spiritual religious
because nine times attended my per this
is just my personal experience when I
talked to spiritual or not really
religious people they lean towards her
more and the religious people lean
towards this it does but they're on both
sides it happens but what I'm saying is
Pearl you're saying you had a sibling
raised beautifully out of adoption right
zubi saying he doesn't believe in
abortion is taking human life Auntie's
saying the same thing this young woman
is saying a very different thing but
it's based in her personal experience in
life and so on and so forth which is
okay I'm just saying I don't believe in
abortion but at the same time I don't
think I can tell a woman or anybody what
to do with their person so I'm in this
weird place of it you're comfortable
telling someone not to kill someone all
right
well for different reasons
that's a different podcast topic I'm
comfortable somebody's coming for me
about an innocent life we're not talking
about
innocent so for me I'm saying from my
background I can't
tell somebody not I mean I think is it
but for innocent live zubi I agree with
you I agree with you can can anyone else
comment on whether they would because I
was actually yeah go go go police yeah
no I wanted to hear what you would
oh why bring me up
2.0 to be honest yeah I hear what
everyone's saying everyone has got like
um reasonable uh a reasonable standpoint
for what they're saying but me
personally like um I I've done a tick
tock where I said um for instance one
point broke people shouldn't be having
kids because you bring kids into a life
of struggle and hardship see what I'm
saying I think especially someone like
me who came from
um a background of struggle and hardship
like wearing hand-me-downs and all of
this and getting laughed and bullied and
all of that and stuff like that
um
some people just not meant to have kids
bro and your case is just mild you know
this in it what you're talking about
saying that you came from hardship your
smile in comparison yes I'm just saying
as for my experience you know like and
from what I've seen like I've Got
Friends that like whom like their their
parents were crackheads like do you know
what I'm saying like they just were
waste men waste women whatever and
they've just been freestyling through
life and their life has been hardship so
like I get where you're coming from 100
I get where you're coming from because I
came again like my mom very very hard
Pentecostal Church Nigerian woman like
bro like no messing around in it like
you know what I'm saying so I get I get
where you're coming from and where
zooby's coming from it's an innocent
life but it's just like well at the end
of the day everyone's gonna have to
answer for their own actions at the end
of the day I can't judge somebody and
say oh why did you do that like bro like
I don't know their situation but some
people know that bro if I have a kid I'm
gonna miss this kid's life up bro
I have a question do you think and this
is kind of both of you do you think that
poor people are less valuable than rich
people because because when you a lot of
people don't know this but that's a
common argument that people you use for
eugenics it's not about so so basically
so basically that that poor people
should be eradicated and in some of like
the founders plan Planned Parenthood
which is more of a uh it's more of a U.S
organization like that was what they
were fighting for was Eugenics
um which is like basically poor people
should die same with like minorities no
no it's not poverty it's about trauma
it's about trauma it's about passing on
unhealed Souls not going to then go
because her people do you think do you
think that we're spoiled because even
like people that are in like the lowest
income bracket now they're still richer
than most people were in all of human
history and so then like because by that
logic then everyone pretty much should
have died all the time no this is the
thing like I'll tell you something I
grew up privileged then my dad passed
away my life turned around and I came to
England and all of a sudden I went from
being up there to being down here and
being the poor kid but not none of that
situation changed my happiness because
my mom is a loving woman who did
everything to make sure that we were
happy we're okay we didn't have all the
money and yet all her support and love
coming to be a woman that I am today I'm
grateful for that on the flip side I
have friends that went through similar
things all completely different
situations where their parents were not
equipped to give them the love and the
support that they needed to be wholesome
human beings wholesome adults that can
actually lead a life responsibly and not
have to have those traumas about getting
them to get themselves in trouble that's
why people go that's why a lot of black
people go to prison okay so next
question do you where where's the cut
off then like where should abortion be
legal what about what about nine months
no that feel like that's just okay okay
so so what what point he's like I could
say probably to the point where the
brain starts to develop because once the
brain starts to develop properly then
that's when you that's when the life
like the more Consciousness starts to go
and when you're actually picking up a
lot of the the signals from the outside
where your the fetus turns into actually
something that's aware yeah aware yeah
that's it brain waves are what about six
weeks so you would say six weeks well
that's still not developed enough that's
just brain no you said the brain this is
the thing once your brain there's
different stages to it so when when the
brain is development developing there's
brain waves and then there's other
things that you receive certain
information it depends on the level of
information that that brain can now
process okay so what level of
information well I would say probably
the cut off point of three to four
months is actually quite good and I know
they go up to six months yeah it's six
months in the UK and after six months if
there is any even a minor disability
such as a cleft palate
um or something you know something that
minor and there's no limit that's the
current rule in Canada There's No Limit
period many states in the U.S There's No
Limit can I just add a lot with the
question you asked me across like at the
end of the day my mindset to it it's not
about poor people being less valuable
like that's not even what we're talking
about well what I'm talking about what
I'm saying is at the end of the day if
you know you're living and this is a
very common thing yeah a lot of times
people who are living in struggle and
poverty who can't even look after
themselves they just [ __ ] him yeah like
they have nothing else going on
hold on let me just say this bro like
yeah and then they just bring uh they
just having kids bro like you could just
go outside you're going to see people
pushing prams and like they're nothing
going on and their kids bro a lot of
these kids what what happens to them
join gangs uh crime they go prison end
up in the ground whatever bro like so
like all of these other fairy tales oh
yeah maybe they're gonna end up being
just yeah it happens but bro it's rare
really and truly majority of them gonna
end up those actually aren't the women
getting abortions only eight percent of
women below the poverty line are getting
abortions were one out of three women
that make over forty seven thousand
dollars per year actually
your question was about the people that
was in poverty yeah but I'm saying like
like those
like I'm saying when you argue that like
you're basically like you might not mean
it like that but when you're arguing
that those people should get abortions
you're basically saying that poor people
should never write each other
for example yeah you are like let's say
25 you go to the club and you meet this
[ __ ] but he's hot and he decides to
have a one-night stand I know you decide
to open your legs that should fall blah
you get pregnant now cool you are having
your own issues in life you are and
definitely not equipped to be a mother
you're not even responsible whatever and
the guy on top of that he's not a
partner that is going to be able to even
support your child in many ways there
you go it's your decision if you want to
dominate the determinated
money it's about mental it's about how
how prepared are you as a person and if
you're afraid and you don't want to do
it okay but just be ready to deal with
the consequences
actually like you know contraception yes
that's what I have to say yeah
there's so much conception so when
you're in that stage where you're having
the pregnancy what have you done to
prevent that I understand Auntie's
situation was very you know it happened
I'm an exception to every Rule and I
accept that yeah there is contraception
like involved to stop these things
happening and we've completely ignored
that and went on to the fact that we've
been Reckless and we're pregnant so what
what concepts yes
I very much no I've got no kids
really for a guy all you can do is wear
condoms so really who really is in
charge
who's got more Authority in that yeah
because my in my opinion I think women
really need to do a better job of like
um making sure that they don't fall into
that trap because the majority of the
contraception is down to their minute
like you know what I'm saying and then
even let's say even if you have a
girlfriend and you get her pregnant and
she doesn't want to have the kids she
ain't having it bro thanks yeah so
do you think that um Plan B is an
abortion because I always get this
question and I don't know enough about
it it would depend on exactly how it
works
um I don't know next day the the next
day
I know what it is I'm talking about the
actual mechanism by which it works does
it prevent the fertilization
I actually don't understand it
if it prevents fertilization it does
okay if it prevents fertilization then
no that's not enough I don't think I
think they all stop the embryo from
attacking that's what he said prevent
yourself from from the beginning but
it's already fertilized right when the
sperm touches the egg that's already
like has conception already is it is it
a contraceptive a is
I've tried to actually find the answer
to this yeah and it seems to be a little
bit up in the air that so he's only all
right as long as the egg the the touch
of thing he's like
I care about being elect intellectually
honest and consistent right so human
life begins at conception right left
uninterrupted from that point this is
why it's dumb when people make that
point oh well masturbating is the same
as it's like no because the sperm on its
own doesn't do anything it never
develops into a human an egg on its own
does not but once they meet if we were
to rewind any of our lives and go back
to where our life began it would be from
that moment of conception that's when
the DNA that that that's when the full
okay
up to five days after oh it does the
sooner you take it because you don't
know whether it's going to get
fertilized or not so the earlier you
take it yeah it will that that's why I'm
saying
depend on so as far as I'm concerned if
it's within 72 hours I'll say yeah if
it's within five days and you can go as
far as five days now what I'm trying to
say is that 72 hours 72 hours you know
there's no not going to be any
fertilization because it's like that
yeah the five days is a bit iffy look
can I just say that yeah sure everybody
keeps on talking about
trauma
and everybody keeps on blaming
everything nowadays on trauma
but if I can have counseling and
cognitive therapy back in the 80s and
90s it's available out there for
everybody and more women especially
women
they need to start going and getting
therapy because I'm I'm sick and tired
of hearing about people's trauma
nowadays I've got to the point where
I've had much from within you I don't
care about yours because you're wearing
it like a badge you know like oh I'm
doing this because I've got this trauma
oh nobody's had if I wanted to nobody in
their life has had more trauma than I
have I wear my healing as my badge as
soon as you as soon as you get like you
get grapes go and get counseling I did I
got abused go and get counseling that
counseling didn't work go and get one
that works for me and that's what I did
I don't carry around baggage I do with
it and I leave it and I move on as a
whole human being I'm not going to turn
around and say oh it was a great victim
and and
no can I just say something I'm sick and
tired of hearing about people's trauma I
don't care about nobody's trauma
definitely deal with it can I just say
something do you know who also needs a
lot of therapy demand them too because
men carry a lot of trauma and they don't
talk about it so actually they become a
lot of the victims that deal with things
that's in the like quietly and then they
start hurting other people too it's not
just the women women need men need um
therapy too but the whole point is that
when men have trauma they use their
penises and vaginas to get rid of their
trauma and guess what then it's gone and
then they get the girls that don't want
to have babies pregnant
that is why when the women have issues
before they go and sleep with these kind
of men
that's why they need to have them
because people are saying oh um I came
from a single parent family that Mama I
was raising my Mom and Dad my mom and
dad got divorced and my mum raised me on
her own and I I've got Trauma from then
have I got trauma no oh my parents sent
me to um
um Africa when I was a child and I've
got trauma I got sent to Barbados have I
got trauma no I got sent away from my
parents for to go to school have I got
trauma no I'm sick and tired I got
graped so did I they ain't reported it
I've done it I got I reported it
you know it's got to the point where I
get sick of watching certain programs
especially stupid programs like
EastEnders and and and and Emmerdale
because something would happen at the
end of it if you're affected by this
program please phone this number you
know and then you'd have people saying
oh I got graped and I was watching this
program and it brought it all back to me
did you find the number at the end no
because you like are you enjoying your
pain some women enjoy that pain around
it's a trophy nowadays it's part of like
um
everyone uses these kind of identity
topics as a way of as an honor right
like a feminist will most feminist I've
met will have some kind of trauma like
this and they they talk about therapy
they'll never use it and they'll keep on
doing the same dumb stuff because it's
like a you know but um on that point the
initial question was I wouldn't date
someone who who had an abortion just
because in my experience I'm pro-choice
but I've seen it's extremely traumatic
and like those women are never the same
again that's one thing people don't tell
you people people are liking just having
a problem those women those women like
it does mess you up and I think it's
abortion is a horrible horrible thing
and I think it should be avoided at all
costs
like and like I said you have to you
have to deal with the consequence I'm
not gonna lie one of the things I agree
with Auntie for sure people tend to be
very mentally weak and that goes on both
sides women and men that's why I said
men need therapies all their weakness is
just displayed in different ways because
at the end of the day if you're going to
make that decision you make it logically
as well if you even make it emotionally
there's there's logic behind your
emotion that's why therapy works because
there's a certain logic so if you're
logical about it you get over it so
instead of you thinking about I wouldn't
be with a girl that doesn't that has had
an abortion maybe start thinking I
wouldn't be with somebody that is
unhealed because everybody goes through
everything you're just healing you grow
from it no I think I think it just I
think it just says that you're selfish
because because you're thinking because
you're thinking of yourself before the
child and like and the thing about the
child trust me my sister I could be a
mother anytime I believe I'll be a great
mother however I believe that I I would
prefer to put my child in a situation
where I know you're not going to be
abused because the father is just but
then like women that are actually
selfless will leave that situation and
figure out a way to to raise them they
don't just say oh me me me me I'm first
yeah and there's some women are selfless
but they still don't know what they're
doing and they end up ruining the
child's life
because they have fatherless again again
so that that happened sure but usually
those women are selfish too because I'm
sorry you can't like like the women of
my my moms and like older generation
they don't do this [ __ ] all around the
freaking world man it's just here
um by the way just one thing about this
conference just to take it up one level
one thing I always find frustrating
about this conversation and I've
discussed this many many times over the
years with people of course I have
strong feelings I know the pro-life pop
position is not the most popular one in
the modern Western World um but I
believe it's the correct one
and one thing that's always frustrating
about these conversations is people both
men and women act like we don't know how
babies are made right there's very
little talk about personal
responsibility self-control discipline
making wise decisions it's just do
whatever you want the truth is
Society wants people to just to be able
to just do whatever have sex with
whatever whoever don't think about it
and you no have no consequences you can
always you know get rid of the evidence
that's what the truth is where you know
when people are jumping to these very
rare cases extreme cases of incest or
extreme cases of of grape and so on and
so forth they're really distracting from
99 of the issue and I wish people could
just be more honest about it and we
could have that talk about
responsibility and proper sexual
behavior and being being careful being
cautious making better wiser decisions
democracy Upstream so that we're not
we're not dealing with I think I think
people regardless of the different
positions here hopefully I think we'd
all agree that ideally
things should not even get to that
situation right and the truth is we have
we have so many ways now let's be real
we have so many ways to avoid that we've
got guys here who are in their in their
30s you know you've managed to make it
through without having a kid and getting
anyone pregnant and so on it's it's not
it's not impossible it's not rocket
science but you do have to be careful
and make wise decisions can I just give
you a scenario what if you you meet a
girl
you use protection the condom breaks you
don't know this girl I wouldn't have sex
with a girl I don't know listen
I'll tell you my perspective I think
that if you are going to have sex with
someone there is always a possibility
that a child will be a result of that
always a possibility you can lower that
probability to
0.0001 but if you're having sex with
someone especially on on a regular
especially if you're not using
protection and contraception then there
there's a there's a possibility for that
have you ever had a one night stand
before
[Laughter]
let me answer the question
if that happened
I would you know we live in this weird
world where the man only gets so much
say in these things but I would strongly
I would be like yo I got this I got you
I've got you right if that is the
situation and that happens I will step
up I will take my responsibility
that's my choice
I'm stepping up to get the morning after
pill but
but if you're man enough to do what you
did then you should be man enough to
take the responsibility
regardless you knew there was a chance
the women take responsibility as well
100 absolutely it takes two detangle
yeah like we all know how this stuff
works like I said the truth is people
want to be a men and women want to be
able to go out have complete random sex
be as promiscuous as they want whatever
and not face any of the consequences
and by the way Society did not used to
be like this
exercise
people need to start talking to their
children from Young I mean my
grandchildren are on the five
and I will talk to them about sex
education down to them who can touch
where you know whatever's underneath
your swimming culture is your area not
even glamor wash it because I don't wash
them because I'd like to say not even
glamor you know they know how to wash
themselves properly on their own
age one age two three and five
and my brother's dad died when he was
three years old
and I stepped in to help my mom I was a
child myself
and the way I the way I raised helped my
mum raise my brother
he went on a date when he was I think 14
of a girl though I didn't particularly
like her I thought she was a bit forward
you know and you can tell that she
didn't come from a good household you
know you get them girls that come in
they're over friendly they want to start
helping doing this and doing that and it
was kind of weird and then he was going
to take you on a date and I'd always put
my brother up to let him know
16 is the age when you start having sex
and I petrified him I terrorized him
because I told him if you have sex on
the 16th the police will come and arrest
you
because it's against the law to this day
he still remembers of that and he still
tells me off that you had me terrified
and he said that I remember he went out
with this girl and I taught him about
going out on dates and he said oh she
won the kiss goodnight and I thought
he came home and he was really upset he
was storming around I think he was about
14 13 14. I said what's wrong because
she asked me for a kiss because you know
she's trying to stick her tongue in my
mouth he goes what kind of rubbish is
that he said I went on a date with her
because I told him about you know being
a gentleman and going on a day and stuff
and retrain my brother even his wife now
he's 40 and even his wife now when they
when she came around after the wind
dating and engaged you know my mom and I
you met my mum Grace's Pearl's new
granny and were you my mom I mean she in
her day she was hilarious we used to go
into the chemist and like Pharmacy and
big one they had condoms on offer
you know he was over 16 and we said oh
they've gone buy one get one free my mom
would be shouting out these ones are
colored these ones have got knobs and my
brother used to get really embarrassed
because we used to buy him condoms there
was always and people oh you're
encouraging him to have sex no we're
encouraging that if he's gonna have sex
have it safely and he he ended up
dumping that girl because she wanted him
to have sex
and in the back of his mind he knew he
was going to get arrested and locked up
but he's happily married now he's
happily married now with two lovely
children and because of the way he was
raised good he was raised like that and
he had he had a fantastic death his late
dad was absolutely fantastic
better than my dad and my mum and dad
were married seriously better than my
dad but it needs to start from Young
because these modern women are going out
and the when you see the children of
these modern women you can see where
they're coming from where they're going
to end up and it takes a village I don't
see any
grandmothers I don't see people coming
around for dinner
you know I mean the first time I met
Pearl I had to go into Pearl's Place I
took around some drinks and snacks and
she was like oh but to me that's you you
do that I'm coming around there to spend
time with you you know I've had
children's you know people bringing
their children into my back Garden I
teach them how to you know where
potatoes come from to dig potatoes you
know I'm teaching my nephew how to make
bacon where bacon comes from because
there's not part of a pig called bacon
you know and things like that so if
people are teaching their children from
Young
extremely young now because it seems
like the age of having sex I mean I told
my brother 16. you know he was born in
1982 I think I was the name a 1985. I
was telling him 16. but now I'm married
at people having sex when they're 12.
so and and even younger so you need to
teach the children from Young
and everybody needs to teach I could
walk into East ham and I can where I
used to live and I can see children
misbehaving and I will stop them tell
them off
they won't say another word they won't
go until their mother even where I live
now I don't know who they are I live by
a school and if I see children playing
up you know especially if there's the
white children they're giving their
mouth a bit like hey you're making that
night you know and the parents you can
tell they're grateful you know thank you
and there's no Village anymore
there's no Village anymore and that's
why these children are being turned up
to be like
fast cars and can I say one thing though
can I say one thing yet like what you're
saying like 100 yeah I'm with you but we
live in a different time why do people
keep on saying that about changing it
there's all these positive people in
here there's all these positive people
in here there's all these people
watching the podcast and you can't just
sit back and allow it to happen I don't
allow it to happen if I went into your
house and you had children there and
they were misbehaving I'm not going to
sit there and shut up I want to put them
straight so if you can't say that no
this is otherwise we might not what's
the point of having this podcast trying
to change it if it's never going to
change I agree with you I know but we
are not you can't just say we it's
different times now thinking well
nothing's going to change the difference
no but what I'm trying to say is that it
will change it doesn't matter whether
it's different times now because
everything needs to turn back to
traditional because that's what needed
so even though times have changed now I
still have modern people with their
children in my house they're quite
happily drop them over for a bit of
discipline because they listen to you
you know my house I mean I haven't got
no kids in my back Garden is full of
like swings and slides and art stuff and
whatever and I have them all around so
I'm gonna make the change it's gonna
start with me it can start with you it
can start with everybody else there's no
point saying oh this is the way it is
it's lost it's not going to change that
was back in the day because I'm people
might say that I've always been in the
world but not of it so a lot of things
that happen out there don't affect me
because I'm not actually of the world
I'm just I'm just in it so as far as I'm
concerned in my little world
I don't get affected by that all the
children that come into my little world
they will never get affected by that
because I'm going to give them the same
base the same Foundation that I had and
if people start stop thinking oh you
know this is going to be they want to
teach my son about um Guru nanak when he
was in Primary School
and I said no put him in a different
class let him do some maths in English
you know sex education I had to go and
find out what it was all about before
because I knew that if it was a sex
education now there's no way you're
teaching my son and I'd actually go into
the school and say I don't want him in
there put him in another class because
they knew me well in Brampton Manor
because I was always down there walking
down there sort out the teachers and the
Headmaster but no people need to get
involved because I'm tired of hearing to
say oh it's different now nothing's
going to change nothing's going to
change because people are just sitting
about saying it's different now or
having talked about it without doing
something about it what I said though I
didn't say any of that what did you say
yeah I said it's a different time now
that's what I said and then you went on
no but it's a different time it's a
different time so let me finish what I'm
saying yeah at the end of the day as I
said initially I agree with what you're
saying yeah why it's a different time he
said but yeah and you didn't let me
finish so can I let me say what I'm
saying yeah at the end of the day my
ideology to it is we need a different
strategy to this because the the older
people of your generation and or
whatever like my mom's generation or
whatever yeah their mindset is of of how
it was when they were younger or how it
applies now it's not necessarily the
same kind of ball game you have to
evolve you have to evolve with the times
like you get what I'm saying like the
kids like for instance kids nowadays do
not care about who's older or who's
younger I know when I was young if if an
older guy came to me and said something
I'll be shook you know what I'm saying
you think the kids now are shook they
are not scared bro they're out of me
I've never met I have never ever you
going you can go and bring me the worst
kid ever and I'm telling you bring me
the initial challenge if you've got a
child
bring me the worst child ever I will
have your child for a weekend bring me
your child I've got cameras in my house
you can see what I do and I will hand
your child over to you at the end of the
weekend a different child I will
guarantee you that because I've been
doing it for years because people drop
off their children to me regularly
Auntie yeah I hear your point I hear you
there's no contingency plan because us
the new generation we're formulating or
farming kids in this new school of error
and I feel like I understand your point
we need to adopt and keep the stand at
the same height because at the moment
we're conforming to society and making
it seem that what's [ __ ] excuse my
language is okay yeah and that's the
problem you need a good foundation right
though mind you though I again I don't
know I can't believe I'm agreeing with
you
this is not about conformities about
evolving you can't go back you need to
go up and that means like you said you
need to move with the times because
people may have the similar foundations
to what they would have had before but
the ideals and what the way people see
the world is different so you need to
communicate with them differently so we
can't just try and discipline people the
same way and give them certain models
that no longer are valued in the world
that they're in today because as much as
you want to influence that person
there's a million other people and a
million different things that they see
every single day that influences them
even more than you you're just one voice
out of so many so again like he said
it's about evolving with the times we
can't go back
how did you evolve what do you mean
evolved I think we need to explain the
fact that the new generations believe
extremely in the freedom of expression
the freedom of self you are who you are
you have your opinions that's why a lot
of people
so if people are believing in freedom of
expression believing in the freedom of
self you need to actually speak to
people in a way where you still going to
say to encourage that but you're going
to also try and supplement that you
can't force and you can't say this is
how it should be this is how it's going
to be instead potentially start doing
things a little bit more entertaining
that that communicate with what they
know because one thing that again I was
a teacher I know that you know
I was a special education to like
measure myself with anyone I'm
explaining things from my experience and
what my perspective on this is the point
is people switch off the moment that
things don't seem interesting to them so
you need to speak to them on the level
and speak to them in the language that
they speak that's why he'll say people
right now if you go as an adult I've
I've had to have serious challenges with
kids because they don't respect my
authority because I'm an adult because
it starts at home
do not go against some of the ideals
that your parents brought you up with to
an extent but all I'm saying is your
life someone said at the start of this
whole thing your foundations they start
at home whatever you learn if your
parents are swearing 24 7 you're going
to pick that up if your parents are holy
you're gonna pick up whatever you now go
to a different Community or whatever and
you learn from that Community it's then
now up to you to decide what you're
going to do kind of thing yeah I mean I
look for my stuff at home the
foundations and yes I've learned from
other people but if I now go with what
I've learned in my communities where I
grew up I'd be Wayward right now yeah
and that's the facts of the fact the
issue now is that people both parents
work now so people kids are raised by
the state like we all got our idea of
how uni was from American Pie we get our
ideas from dating from TV we all get I
so I you know as much as I understand
Auntie sentiments I think you can't
really turn back that clock for a number
of reasons you don't really have
lifetime jobs like that so people way
more mobile than they used to be you
know there's all these all these
International factors that that kind of
mean that communities can't can't be as
stable and last as long as they used to
be back okay
oh XYZ kid has got this phone that's so
important let me tell you one thing let
me tell you one thing let me tell you
one thing the meta verse is coming let
me tell you one thing can't you control
what your kid like you don't have to
have your kids have a phone and also
like if you don't if you don't like this
if you don't like the school system I
mean I don't know how it works in the UK
but like in the US you can homeschool
yeah
and you can and you can raise them in an
environment where you like you have
relatives and you have good people that
are influencing them around like around
them
who wants to be friends with their kids
you're not friends no no absolutely
different man yeah but you know what you
know why that is because a lot of these
people are having kids while they're
still kids themselves that's the problem
that's one but plus two when this new
modern day where it's like oh you can't
do this
but at the end of the day you gotta
discipline your kid and they should
discipline each other bring back
bullying
if you weren't called ugly once in your
childhood it was too good
how humbling them
that's why I think it's so important to
have like masculine role models in in
culture because I think right now a lot
of our issues are from you know the
mainstream media kind of feminizing men
yes and so these boys are growing up and
I was a teacher
wait wait what are you talking okay what
do you what do you explain I'll explain
shortly and like five sentences
nowadays nowadays men are just like us
Petty men are just like yeah because we
we made them that way no because because
how many times has girl have girls said
I want a guy that's emotionally
available it's crazy because we only
fight for men's rights when it benefits
us because we like we want them to be
more emotionally available for us we
don't like that he's not even about so
that's why we tell many men are not the
ones leeching off the woman right that's
feminine to me okay okay
if you like bums speak for yourself
everywhere
I think it's just the guys that you date
are bombs so you can you can speak for
yourself
no no stop stop stop stop stop stop
go to South London my sister okay okay
oh my God like if you're dating bums
that's on you that like most women are
more broke than men even if they out
earn and we outspend them we make 70 to
80 of consumer buying decisions we own
two-thirds of the world's debt we we
don't make good monetary decisions how
are you gonna go to men and say you guys
are the broke ones we're the broke ones
you don't know how to manage our money
and we make less in the UK I don't think
it's quite like that a lot of women in
the UK actually you're right yeah just
whatever no no okay you're correct
you're you're correct you're correct
like like some women under 30 like do
out earn men in certain cities but we
still out spend them so it's like you
think you're the [ __ ] but you you
outspend them well I make my money I'll
spend for me and then not only that
because we are spending because we got
Financial power then that's why a lot of
men now see that as a plus and they
start leaching off it again feminization
if you like bomb speaker yourself
can I say something so basically like
let's go back to traditional homes so a
man is basically like he's the head of
the family he he like pays for
everything right or like sometimes if
your mom wanted to go grocery shopping
or get stuff for the house or manage the
house your dad would give her the money
and then she would manage it would she
not like she would be like okay this
goes for groceries this goes for this
this goes for that so how could you say
like women are bad at managing money
because because statistically we are we
hold most of the words world's debt we
make most of the consumer buying
decisions we hold most of the world's
debt that's why we're bad with money
even though we make less money where is
it found
you can you can literally
it's a worldwide we all hold two-thirds
of the world's debt or the world's debt
worldwide
anecdotally how many of us have our
freaking nails done here let's use the
anecdotal like that's what I'm saying we
spend money on stupid [ __ ]
what did she think she ain't said
nothing
about the conversation yeah but what
part there's been a lot of difference
all right so about like girls like
spending money on junk and stuff like
that would you do you agree with that or
yeah I feel like the the
um world that we're living in at the
moment is like really consumer based
that social media adverts you talk about
something it pops up
um I don't know too much about
statistics of men and women but I I
believe yeah can I make a point where a
lot of times the the phrase the world is
being used a lot the world the world the
world I think it's important to say that
this is largely the modern West thank
you yes this is not the majority of the
world I'd even say that it's very big
city based right the londons the New
York cities the LA's the Miami's the
mentality and the society and the
culture there versus even within the
same country in in more rural areas or
smaller towns or Villages the mentality
is very very different let alone in
developing parts of the world so-called
second and third world countries you
know there's different types of people
everywhere but the mentality is very
different I think that a lot of this is
very much based on actually a small
microcosm of society and we're speaking
as if this is kind of like everyone and
I I don't think it is I I think it's the
it's the I would say big city Modern
mentality I would say I agree with you
100 like because obviously for my
experiences and everything I've already
talked from UK London and in the USA But
the thing is with um the western side of
the world the areas you're talking about
they have the biggest influence yeah
it is relevant to talk about these these
regions yeah I know I'm certainly saying
it's relevant I'm just I'm just saying I
think it's important to be aware for
ourselves and for the audience that this
is not the it's not like a global Norm
a lot of what we're talking about is
actually a global anomaly even when
you're talking about you know oh you
know these kids with single single
mothers it's like that's not the global
Norm the USA has the highest single
Parenthood rate in the entire world
right USA number one that's probably not
one that they should be too proud of I
mean in many many countries like it's
it's very rare yeah even now in 2022
it's rare yeah because in many countries
if you're a single mom you're done
you're done bro like yeah but I'm saying
yeah it's also the culture though it's
what's normalized yeah you know and I
think one one of the big issues we have
in the west and it goes beyond this
issue but it's like we don't even strive
for a good standard anymore and I think
that's a problem right it's one thing to
have a standard and for people to and
understand some people are going to fall
short of it right and we we do this with
everything right even with with health
and fitness oh you can be healthy at any
size body positivity fat except it's
like no it's bad to be obese right yeah
don't get canceled I can't be canceled
I'm immune to this but like but with
everything it seems like we're just say
okay well some people are struggling to
meet the standard so let's abolish the
standard yeah right and I think that's a
really dangerous mentality because you
can just see how the culture is
sliding and sliding and sliding into
this descent and at some point you need
to say tell people look guys we need to
we need to step this up people need to
take responsibility people need to take
accountability we need to empower people
individually
men men women everybody it doesn't need
to be to me it's an adult thing men may
not forced to take accountability women
don't yeah but even a lot man there's a
lot of we can't pretend there aren't
millions of men who are also running
running screaming from it yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
not millions of men who are running from
accountability and responsibility
yeah okay first of all what I've noticed
in my life yeah if you want to talk
about a lot of guys running away from
accountability a lot of times like for
instance with a single mother thing yeah
which is a huge thing in society right A
lot of times these single these that
these guys that are creating these
single mothers they'll have multiple
baby mamas bro multiple these are the
guys that women are gravitating to even
if they know they are adding themselves
to a roster of four let me add myself as
well because he's six foot four because
he's cute because he's funny bro like
come on bro like I don't think it's like
the majority of God I don't even think
it's even 50 of guys who are just
running around recklessly I never said
it works
I say Millions it's Millions yeah yeah
across the West that's what yeah yeah
okay okay but I can still represent a
small percentage though yeah I never
said it didn't yeah I'm just saying yeah
yeah but but when it's like I don't know
what 30 40 of women where it's like
maybe five ten percent of guys like
who's really the problem
and even I I man it's more than 10 of
young men that are not taking proper
responsibility no I I would disagree
because it's not
what
percent
problems let me let me let me let me
what percent of men actually get laid
the other the other guys guys face
consequences for their decisions like
that's the whole point is like sure like
like men when they make a bad decision
they always have a consequence women
don't and that's why women are worse
because one one gender has consequences
one doesn't
say and to say it's like equal I just
think isn't like Fair because like men
when they make a bad decision they have
the consequence immediately where women
don't we're bailed out of everything
everything okay okay okay every bad
decision that you make you're bailed out
of if you want to sleep around there's
birth control if you get pregnant you
don't want to keep it there's an
abortion if you get pregnant and you
want to get married to the guy and leave
and take half you can do that and you
can do it under the guise of being happy
and you know and Society will accept you
and some simple probably marry you after
and then
and then on top of that if you're if if
you're bad with your money what are you
going to do you're going to go to a
women's shelter or the government will
pay you if you also if you leave and
you're a single mother and you're the
fifth baby mama or whatever you can also
go to the government they'll pay you oh
you can cheat you're right you can cheat
and if you cheat and if you cheat
what'll happen oh people ask you well
why did she
cheats
that these systems are put into place
because it is a man's world because us
as women are my now are minorities
that's just lazy
we're the majority
but like in terms of status men rule the
world
media and how you know male stories and
narratives are being kind of feminized
and they're being kind of overshadowed
and demeaned but I was quite interested
to think about say China right which
doesn't really run by our standards and
you see the same kind of um Trend with
pretty boys in China that they've now
banned so I'm just curious as to what
you think about how that Trend can occur
if you're in a country where there's no
feminist right they banned pretty boys
lady boys yeah because they think it's
bad for the states no no no no no no no
no what do you mean like the K-pop like
the like well why didn't ban them I
don't get it because they think it's bad
for young men in China and they don't
want it to affect their youth China's
making specific efforts to try to make
sure a lot of people aren't willing to
do they just don't they just don't they
say we don't want men looking at guys
who wear pink suits some makeup and
K-Pop Stars you don't like that image
we're going to suppress that we want
actual strong guys so I was quite
interested right because China doesn't
have a it's a Communist party right yeah
so and they've got basically no
feminists so who did that is my is my
question what you guys who made the
feminine like the feminist who made it
how could that Trend occur so in the
west I would have said is this
feminization of men there's a lot of
reasons but part of it is this feminist
agenda pushing men to cry more be more
emotional pushing this Narrative of
women strong leaders basically [ __ ]
on men around them and showing how you
know girl power but that doesn't happen
in China so how come China have the same
issue of pretty boys I don't think China
has a massive issue with pretty boys so
why they Banner if they don't have
because they want to nip it completely
in the bud
but why would they nip it if it wasn't a
problem like if it looks because people
still have internet access people can
people can still can still see things
you know you're always you've got 1.4
billion people in China but you know
what he's trying to get out sorry just
to clarify he's basically trying to get
to the point that you're saying that
feminist influences yeah you're blaming
women and feminism giving women too much
voice and he's saying actually in a
place where women don't have much voice
the same things are still happening so
the problem may not be with women the
problem may just be that men actually do
have a tendency to be someone no that's
not what I'm saying
I was just curious as to what what the
other components of that would be if
there's nothing and we don't have this
toxic Western culture attitude
why I mean I would say like it's pretty
blue it's everywhere that's not new it's
always been yeah I mean it's just
whether or not that's the
standards everywhere
because the women like that soft
emotional
male pretty male with the fancy here and
the pretty clothes trying the most well
you don't but thank you they're very
popular all around so maybe that's why
they're nipping it in the bud because
they don't want that sort of man
representing them exactly and maybe we
should have stopped the feminism this
far right feminism nipped it in the bud
before it started yeah
yeah there's different variations of
feminism and just because I kind of feel
like there needs to be equality it
doesn't necessarily make me a feminist I
feel like I'm a humanist
[Music]
yes the only reason like we said that
was because you're repeating like a
feminist argument which isn't which
isn't true we don't live in a patriarchy
women have more power than men
we really do honestly like like I just
think like girls that say that are lazy
and like need an excuse and like yeah
yeah I really I really do because you'll
play a victim yeah because you're able
to acknowledge that there's an issue of
inequality no there's no way yeah
there's no issue with equality well I
know for a certain fact that a woman in
Iran right now just got murdered because
she wasn't wearing her her job properly
that's one way
and not wear appropriate women's
clothing in some areas you will get
lashed you know something like those are
the rules for that particular place so
if you know that those are the rules for
that particular place you abide by the
rules you went in Rome if I went there
and I decided to walk around in a bikini
I would expect to be punished so if you
go there to live by death but you would
know that before you go you wouldn't
because no that is your that is place
where you live when you're going and
traveling do you just go to other
countries and don't look it up
but the woman was Iranian the woman had
a headscarf on her head but she wasn't
wearing it according to someone else's
opinion correctly and so therefore does
that means is that a majority does it
happen yes
if you look at all the women in Iran
that wear hijabs how many percentage is
that a majority or is that a minor
minority
whenever women are trying to it doesn't
matter whatever women are trying to find
something to like you know
um counteract what somebody says it
doesn't always go for the minority
for the majority it's like I need to be
right no no no no listen we always speak
like that I'll tell you something I'm
not saying that it's not an atrocity I'm
saying that it's an atrocity which is a
minority
only in the Western World can we
actually have the balls to say it is not
a man's world Africa Asia Latin American
I think even in the USA maybe only
Europe a little bit where there's not
really like that every single house it
is a man's world the only difference is
a man's weakness is a woman so in a
Mazel the woman does have the power but
it is still a man's world and if you
don't know how to use your power as a
woman then you're inferior and you
succumb to the fact that it's a man's
world and therefore you are unequal
can I can I jump in here with a
hopefully a moderating take is I think
these conversations vary very very
differently depending on if we're
talking about the modern West or if
we're talking about on a global scale
right I think even the concept of
feminism like I have respect for like
Middle Eastern feminists yeah right
feminism in the middle even talk about
feminism in in the Middle East or in in
certain parts of Africa and so on I'm
like I can respect that which is one
reason actually why when modern you know
Anglo women are there talking about we
live in a patriarchy it's like you're in
Canada or something I'm like let's just
stop like just just stop you're just
you're just whining right what more
rights do you want what more rights can
you even can you even get and what's
funny is oftentimes those so-called
Western feminists are very very quiet
when it does come to stuff around the
globe which you could have a legitimate
case of saying okay look at that that
situation is messed up that's not fair
that's truly an equal so I think the
global lens is very different to the
country
when you listen to how they talk you
realize that they're just like in a
state of constant hysteria like the
normal feminist take is to sit around
watching feminist blogs kind of uh
report on like some random thing that
happens to the woman in Australia and
then the feminist comes up and says
that's a sign of how the world is this
woman got killed by a kangaroo in
Australia which means kangaroos hate
women and there's a sexist problem
[Laughter]
I'll be real and I say this is someone
who grew up in Saudi Arabia for 20 years
there there are parts of the world that
could do with a healthy dose of you I
don't even like the term feminism let's
just let's call it let's call it
egalitarianism yeah yeah
which is what she just said and he's not
lazy to say that yeah exactly it's not a
lazy feminism
I'm saying in the West in the West in
the Western and so so we're doing okay
I'm I'm talking about the West I I and
I'm saying if you're in 2022 blaming the
patriarchy for why you cannot succeed as
a woman in 2022 in the west you're lazy
I agree okay and you're just using it as
an excuse I would say because you're
lazy for example in this Western World
and right now one of the issues I have
with a lot of your viewers Pearl no
friends guys but I'll be 15 be is the
fact that actually there's people saying
women shouldn't run Society if I'm just
that's the whole point don't be making
about man and woman make it be about
person person must be capable person
must be aware person must be responsible
it's not about man and woman that's what
we're trying to get at do you get what I
mean
80 of people in Europe believe in gender
equality so this idea that there's
people walk around who are telling you
to go in the kitchen and make sandwich
is nonsense the fact is we all most the
average person absolutely in Europe and
in the west already believes in gender
equality so what are you talking about
so the existence of this specific
podcast in this show and the reason why
we even there's any interest is because
of the fact that this those views are
still existing and they're actually
growing even more now and that's why now
we're having clashes because people are
starting to misunderstand what a modern
woman is they're starting to
misunderstand what the label feminism
means do you get what I mean so at this
point is yeah it's still a man's world
women now want to save forget about
being a man as well it's the person's
world is humans World we're all in it
together let's actually stop trying to
say I'm better and the new and you're
worse than this we if I'm better than
you are doing something I'm better than
you whether I'm a man or woman forget
about that it's that simple quick so
sorry quick one when over man takes you
out will you expect him to pay if a man
takes me out I'll share I'll be like you
know you want to split and if it says
do you know why I do that I do that
because it puts me in a situation to
understand where his mind is at if you
accept me paying I already know what
that says about you
short sure what does it mean about you
it means that you're either just logical
50 50 person you could mean that you're
broke or it could just mean that you're
just like implicated
that goes completely against your
feminist ideology and the whole
everyone's equal though no that's
completely against it that goes down
because this is the problem this is why
people this is what this is okay okay
this is
this is why this is why I have a
platform and I have an audience and
they're not misogynistic they just don't
like that feminist only like equality
when it doesn't or only complain about
equality when it doesn't benefit them
and so so you you like you you enjoy
inequality when it benefits you but when
it doesn't now you're complaining and
that's the whole issue it's not like a
misogyny like the like they hate women
they don't think women can be in charge
whatever it's it's that feminists are
not authentic and they're not honest
okay so and I'm gonna start to interrupt
you my sister let me just explain it to
you okay okay three sentences
if I'm if I'm a woman yeah I was looking
for masculine man actually I would want
you to be better at finances than me
because ideally that's not a headache I
want to deal with I want to deal with a
home so if I'm asking you if you're
gonna pay and you say yes okay it's not
about equality it's about whether or not
you're going to position yourself in
that situation to be better than me
which benefits the partnership because
one day I'm going to be at home having
kids you should be out there working
yeah
but that doesn't necessarily
but if you want to do the traditional
thing you can't pick and choose when to
be traditional you might have to do
everything all the way like okay okay if
you if you want traditional outcomes are
you a virgin no okay so that's what I'm
saying I'm saying how can you ask for
traditional outcomes like the man to pay
when we're not traditional women it's
not about traditional what I don't care
if it's judicial no what I'm but
traditional traditional
Finance one what I want I want to work
hard and I want you to work I want to
work smart I want you to work harder so
those questions that will mean something
if you're financially better than me
quality so that's what I'm saying like
feminists only want equality when it
benefits somebody that works harder
because I work better bringing you want
to depend on him that's why
it's not feminist you want to do this
better than you so you can pay for your
stuff
I want to be in that moment where I'm
testing what you're about I know that
I'm smart I know that if I bring what I
bring to the table is working smart can
you bring to what do you bring what did
you bring to a man do you have
femininity Purity and youth do you have
femininity Purity youth femininity
Purity and intentions and yes
I'm sorry I'm sorry you're 29 that's not
youthful it is
you can be you can't be like close to
halfway through your life and Sam
can I can I just say quickly
to quote somebody that I love uh
women age like milk not like wine uh I
know you hate to hear it
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
why I'm gonna give you why listen to me
so much more than I would have sex I
don't care this is why I can come to you
honestly just a quick question and I
know it sounds weird but let me land as
you say do you think lions and lionesses
have a better relationship than tigers
and tigrises do you know the difference
of those relationships because what
you're describing is a lioness who's not
equal to a lion right but what you want
and what you say and you want is to be a
tigress who's equal to a tiger tiger
says and tigers don't act anyway close
to lines and lionesses you want that
Lion in your house but you also want to
be the lion that's not how that works no
right I want a man that fulfills a role
that I am not going to fulfill that's a
line in line let me tell you what an
education side of things and let me tell
you about it
what you just said is opposite
house a lioness is not equal to a male
lion that's just a fact I'm not gonna
argue with nobody about it there's
Discovery Channel for you there it's
it's Wikipedia there that's equal a
Tigris and a tiger are very much so
equal equals both 500 pounds both can
bench a ton both hunt and live on their
own they come together to mate equally
have their own territory and when they
[ __ ] with each other anybody can get
them hands that's it it don't matter
who's nobody's stronger than the other
they're quite equal a lion
in a lioness
are very different you what you're
describing what you're saying is you
want a man to go and do the things that
you cannot do that's a lion
you want to be a lioness but with all
the benefits of also being the lion that
don't work nowhere in the world and I'ma
just tell you why it don't work and it's
not a disrespect I'm gonna tell you why
it don't work
it's unnatural and I'm not saying that
women are not equal to men because I
just said tigrises are equal to Tigers
I'm not saying women are not equal to
men because a black widow female kills
the male for food I'm not saying that
that can't be a possibility what I'm
explaining to you is everything that
you've said
that I've been listening to I ain't
talking in like 20 minutes I went to pee
I sat down to pee because I got bad
bladder everything that I've said
everything that you've said I just
listened to you talk I listen I didn't
interrupt you I didn't hear nobody else
interrupt you you was going off
you have contradicted yourself about
three or four times hold on and they've
tried to tell you that you contradict
yourself and I'm not saying this in any
other way because you want to be right
baby
I'm finished
this is what I mean and you said you
single I know because you ain't shut the
[ __ ] up okay
[Music]
let him finish I can't tell me why
because if I'm Einstein and I say E
equals and you say I don't think E
equals I didn't say MC squared yet so
you don't know what the hell I'm talking
about so let me finish what I'm saying I
understand what you want
I get what you want
I know what you want but what you want
and what you've said are two different
things and I think he's tried to explain
it I think Auntie's tried to explain it
I even think the young woman who's on
your side here tried to explain it Pearl
tried to explain it they he ain't even
saying nothing no more
I don't know what I'm saying because
you're not psychic that's the problem
that what you're having you're basically
trying to tell me that um
contradict yourself I'm saying what you
want is different than what you've said
and the problem that you're having is
not that you're not that you're
contradicting so everybody contradicts I
contradict myself all the time ask my
baby mama I can't judge himself 24 7.
what you're having the issue that you're
having is that you're struggling with
what Pearl said she hit a nerve she said
you're not young anymore
and you're arguing with her about and
she's right I hate to tell you somebody
said earlier there's 18 year olds born
every day you ain't 18. what you're
arguing with is that you want a man like
you said your words you want a man to do
be better at certain things than you are
that's a lion a lioness is better at
hunting a male lion is better at killing
hyena but in your mind you see yourself
as a tigress you just haven't joined
those thoughts you have to pick what you
want to be you have to pick what you how
you want to present yourself to the rest
of the world and what you want to do you
haven't done that what you've done is
you've gone you just asked this boy I
like you what when were you born that's
not a question okay
no no no you've got a lot of mic time no
let them go
but all I'm saying is this all I'm
saying is I'm gonna let you go bro
because my last point is literally this
what you want in life
you've told us what you want what you
see in a man what you want out of a man
what you think about abortion what you
think about all these topics everything
you've said but
that's what you want
right that's what you want but what
you've said is the opposite of what you
want how you behave is the opposite of
what you want so you have to figure out
on your own this is on your own time
there's a piece for you to take home
with you you got to figure out how to
take what you want
and what you say you want and make them
the same thing and that's why I said
cooperation earlier because you cannot
that's comprom what you're trying to do
is compromise with yourself that's never
going to work you got to cooperate with
yourself and figure it out now I know
you want to talk I know I see it you
can't there's not many things that men
can add to my life that's why
over there here's how you play a
feminist right so you get this girl
she's at the bar she's a feminist she's
talking all this stuff she thinks she's
she's kind of she's kind of arrogant
right she needs to go out she thinks
she's getting a female so what you do is
you don't disagree because feminists are
extremely arrogant so she's gonna
convince herself that she can change you
over the couple of days right you pipe
it for a couple weeks four weeks I'd
recommend it and then you just bounce
that's how you play the feminist so as I
said at the start the Modern Woman
destroys what she loves if she likes you
you get on you smashed whatever the
first thing she's going to try and do is
diminish you she's gonna try and make
you less how she's gonna do this she's
gonna be like you should be more
emotional you should actually tell me
how you feel learn damn well that that's
not why she's attracted to you that's
not why you're there she's going to tell
you all these other things
um so that's how you play the feminist
just saying okay thanks okay so
um I'm gonna close out the show because
it's getting late uh thank you guys for
all coming why why don't we go around
everyone tell the people where they can
find you and any final thoughts that you
have
okay starting starting with you oh all
right great show man find me a bigger
BTV on all platforms YouTube Instagram
Facebook and all that good stuff and
final thoughts is just do you just do
you
um big teaso on Twitter
uh Big Tease on Twitter
Instagram
big teaser one on Snapchat
he's the one on Tick Tock I can't
remember all the handles but yeah Big
teaser you'll find me in it but it was a
good conversation obviously you got a
few different opinions and stuff but
that's live everyone you can't be a yes
man you can't be a no man just gotta
have your opinions and stick by them you
get me
uh all my handles beard gang members
um
the summarize the whole conversation I
think modern women just need to align
what they want and their actions it's
simple I agree with uh what he just said
that's it you just have to align what
you want in your actions and what you're
saying they have to align if they don't
align it it's never going to work uh my
handles it doesn't matter I don't want
you to follow me on social media because
I don't care about you I don't know
you're a stranger I don't care about
your opinions I'm never going to comment
to you but I'm on Pearl's story I'm I'm
sure I'm on somebody else's story if you
feel like you want to you can do it I've
got comedy specials on Amazon Prime uh
you can find them through the links in
my bio I have got an old podcast that I
don't do anymore uh with all my terrible
opinions on there too but if you go to
Pearl's story you'll see me tagged I'm
standing next to her like a goofball I
look ridiculous I saw the picture is bad
for me for me and so I'm I'm standing so
just find me their feel
uh also really really quick just from
looking at the chat guys I'm gonna Read
Super chats after they do their final
thoughts um we had a lot of people today
and I was just trying to let everyone
like get in so I I know there's a lot of
super chats I haven't read but yeah
we're gonna we're gonna finish the show
possibly getting roasted sorry guys okay
go ahead uh you can find me at
santochuku
um it's on Paul's Instagram story uh my
final message will be uh to young men
especially out there is that you're
being lied to your whole life you're
being you're being told and conditioned
into being kind of an ideal that the
Modern Woman does not want and is not
attracted to so if you need some support
if you need any help I'd recommend
Jordan Peterson I'd recommend Andrew
Tate I'd recommend myself my channel I'm
starting like a Consulting thing because
I've realized a lot of men just haven't
had a masculine figure in their life so
they actually don't understand what
masculine's problem-solving thinking is
they get all their opinion from dating
channels and like some therapist who was
like raised in feminist ideology
um so you can reach out on there and
just know your worth boys respect
yourself control your sexual urges don't
be out here piping you know one out of
tens and stuff like that yeah
what what's the minimum fours fives I'll
say I'll say a six
okay okay
[Laughter]
it's all depending on your level as well
don't be thinking you're part of your
babies if you shot a 10 early you can
become a Sim because they catch feelings
they're like oh I'm never gonna no
listen you can let go of the six anytime
in it
um you can find me on Instagram at who's
underscore Amber Jade my music's on all
major platforms if you just type Amber
Jade
um today I found it very interesting it
was good to hear all different
perspectives and what I'll take away
from it is that just live your life and
do what feels best for you obviously try
and be considerate but people are people
at the end of the day so yeah
yo obviously kid riches on uh YouTube uh
Ambitions of power on Instagram yeah
listen
um my opinion with the Modern Woman
where like it's just like what my
brother over here said like bro like at
the end of the day you gotta know what
you want and then align yourself with
what you want bro like I think a lot of
people men and women out here are
confused yeah um they've got a lot of
their teachings from cardi B city girls
and that and a lot of guys they've got
their teachings from their favorite
rapper do you get what I'm saying that
is not actually really reality you know
what I'm saying so
um like if you are the kind of guy who
you know you wanna if you're in that
space where you want to settle down and
that then you've got a kind of pattern
yourself to be that guy that the woman
you want wants to be with and then it's
not exactly the same with women in life
you know you want to be with a guy
that's going to be faithful and he's
family orientated you need to be the
same you can't be hot girl summer and
then think that oh yeah I'm gonna get
wifed up bro no you're gonna get tossed
up like you know like you're throwing
your box around to pattern up in it like
everyone needs to just be on their thing
also last thing um there's a lot of guys
out there that are um experiencing like
mental illness like through different
factors in life I know we were touching
it very briefly um I'm someone that went
through depression like make sure you
find someone to speak to about your
problems and that because I think it
kind of gets like swept under the carpet
a lot of times people just don't really
care what men are going through and are
not I know a lot of guys are watching
this so um that's another Point
um and yeah make sure you're making the
best version of yourself don't just do
it for girls do it for yourself do it
for your future in it like you know what
I'm saying but anyway go subscribe to my
channel King riches uh go check me out
on the fresh and fair I was on there
yesterday go check out that video we got
to Jeff pearly things if you're not
subscribed yeah we've got beef
we've got beef now in it so make sure
you subscribe to this channel stay
locked all right safe
who's next um you can find me on
YouTube pearls yeah we're we're trying
to get her Channel up by October 30th so
because
yeah because of all this had to take all
my personal stuff off of my Instagram
and take it off private and just leave
it there but there's yeah nothing on
there yeah watch first I do food and
grocery Bargains On Tick Tock and now
and then she's gonna start reacting to
Modern women tick-tocks
start start teaching her to cook
she didn't understand it she's like why
do I have to clean the chicken
and I just think that why why yes no
what I took from this but what I'm
putting into this is that it takes a
village
and everybody needs to be part of a
village Wherever You Are nowadays it's
too easy just to be there and you're
friends with 2 000 people but do your
neighbors know who you are hello
you know I've got there's a I've got old
neighbors there's an old white lady next
door I get a barber getting well with
her and there's a cantankerous Oman
across the road
and I love him dearly I moved in and I
heard him say so to someone get off my
[ __ ] wall
you know and I was just I love him and I
They See Me Knocking on his door and
going in he'll come into my house he'll
bring me my my favorite marks and
Spencer ginger cookies and you know
be part of a village you know I I'm I'm
the sort of person that I got two lots
of school uniform for my grandkids
before they started I couldn't remember
what color so I got red and blue and it
turns out they were blue so I had all
this red I live near a school I just
stood outside the front door on the
first child that I saw with their parent
walking past
I said are you going to school and and
it just happened to be a little girl
just started and I said hang on a minute
wait there anyway Madara won't come out
you know this white man you know with
his kid what does she want and I said I
bought it for my grandkids I bought red
and blue
they have blue you can have the red and
every morning I see that little girl
look at my window boss and sometimes I
give her a little wave you know and
it takes a village if you see somebody
old and you see somebody of a different
culture or something
shut the hell out of them by saying
hello good morning you know you can just
make somebody's day especially nowadays
the way things are if you're black and
you see an old white person
you say good morning good morning you've
made that person's day you might have
changed their whole life and I just
think the village mentality is where it
starts and as far as I'm concerned start
on the kids in the primary school
because I for me that's why I only
fostered primary school children because
I think those are the ones that are more
palatable those are the ones you can
change Easier by the time you hit
secondary school I can't do that but
start young start young and be a village
I want to hear what your neighbors are
saying about you I would like to hear
what your friends have said and don't
listen to your female friends listen to
your male friends and that's what I can
say be part of a village I think once we
have once we have Villages then the
world become a lot better place we start
going back to how it was and
all this technology I just wanted to say
when Mr always technology when my son
was little everybody had mobile phones
he even saved I think Coca-Cola token so
you can get his free mobile phone and I
said you're not 16. and somebody said to
me oh Jennifer my sons have got phones
and there was like I said why why your
son got phone this is I know where they
are I said I know where my son is 24
hours a day he don't need a phone for
that because he knew that even though I
was working if he came home from school
and I want to see you phone me from the
house number
by a certain time
if you're 15 minutes late phoning me
you take away half an hour of your play
time
and even and no footballs were allowed
in my house and even now when my
grandchildren come my niece and nephew
come
anything that needs a battery or
charging don't bring it it's not coming
in my house we're not doing that we're
gonna bake together we're going to cook
together I've got grafts you know loads
I've got a whole room full of stuff for
children they can go with paint inks
everything and their mum does that as
well
so as far as I'm concerned don't get
caught up because everybody was like oh
I didn't have this when I was young so I
want to give it to my child just because
you didn't have it when we was young it
doesn't mean it's good for your child
did you suffer for not having the latest
phone yeah I mean Cabral talks about
bringing back bullying you don't even
need to bring back bullying give yours
give your child a block Nokia
do you know what I mean
and that will sort them out you don't
need you know take away the Jordans and
give them some feeler or Dunlop Green
Stripe
as far as I'm concerned as far as I'm
concerned that was straight in the mouth
that was straighten them out oh they're
gonna get bullied no because they will
know you know something there's a
there's I think I put it up on my on my
Instagram and there's a boy who they
were taking the Mickey out of him
because he had feelers and he said it's
not what on my feet that counts it's
what's in here yeah and he had that
mentality and I think it was about nine
or ten and that's the mentality we need
to have because if you teach your child
people are doing all these things now
years ago I thought I was shot by the
sweet 16 that was going out you know it
was coming to America a sweet 16 party
if you're giving your child a smartphone
now this now that now what the hell are
you gonna do when they reach 16 and if
they can't afford it then
how are they going to get it
and that's what you gotta think now and
that's why I don't get caught up with
all the modernization about moving on
about this is the way it is because
everybody knows when you step into my
house it's old school
and if you bring your child into my
house I don't I don't believe in
slapping children I don't believe in
physical Corporal points but but if you
bring your child into my house or put me
around your child expect me to
discipline your child as if it was me
because I'm Auntie Jenny everywhere so
from the time my child is calling me
auntie I'm treating you like my niece
and my nephew wherever I go wherever I
go strangers children I don't care don't
put your child near me if you don't want
me to straighten them out I'm also
talking I can just look at the show and
say hey
and they would just stop so I think
that's what that's what needs to come
back we need a village okay
um it's a troublemaker then I'll be
notified me on the novel.io on Instagram
and all over the place just to because I
got the mic now I am a unicorn and I'm
very much aware of that I'm probably one
of them not many women that actually
doesn't need a man I want a man if he's
right which means I've already got a
village I've got a lot of love even to
have a child I don't need a husband
because my mom told me how to show love
on her own not because my dad was a
piece of trash but because he passed
away young and so boys I'm not here to
impress you trying to find a husband
through this I'm here to show you love
me or hate me you love to hate me and
you hate to love me so Ciao Baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
on Instagram and what I took away from
today's podcast is just bring back
traditionalism man that's it
quietly listening yeah so this is zubi
um you can find me on all social media
at zubimusic Zuby music you can find my
music and my podcast real talk with zubi
on all platforms Apple podcast Apple
Spotify wherever you listen and um in
terms of a couple closing remarks on
this conversation I'll keep it rooted on
the topic we discussed first of all I
think people need to recognize that you
can't have both equal treatment and
special treatment right and I think that
individually in society-white people
need to decide do you do they want
equality or do they want special
treatment because this these two things
are not compatible people are are
wanting both when it suits them
different ways I will also say that if
you are someone who is feeling kind of
despondent and concerned about all this
stuff I'll tell you as a man who's
always traveling the world is the world
is a lot bigger than the west and the
world is a lot bigger than whatever
individual City you are in so I am a big
fan of the slogan go where you're
treated best so don't be afraid to move
you may have grown up in London or you
grew up here there go explore your
country go explore the world there are a
lot of great places there's a lot of
great people out there even if it's for
trying to find a relationship if you're
someone looking for something more
traditional there are still billions of
more traditionally minded people out
there so if you're not surrounded by it
you can put yourself in a position where
you can still find people who are like
that and you don't need to date the
entire world you only need that one
person so that would be my closing
remark you can follow me on all social
media at zubimusic right
um this is Iman
um you can find me at the chocolate High
uh the dot chocolate hi on Instagram or
Neptunia Nubian neptunian.nubian
um this is my first podcast and I can
say that I've learned a lot from each
and every one of you
um I would engage I would like encourage
more of this conversation and like I
would encourage self-awareness as well
like it all kind of
starts with from within like you need to
kind of I mean we not to sound negative
but we kind of live in a very shallow
toxic society and things need to change
and it comes from within not to be as
cliche but that's what I have to say
that was real that was real yeah yeah
thank you guys for coming I know it's
late and I know
um that this is like a crowded panel
today and honestly we didn't do too bad
with over talking for how many people we
had so yeah they did yeah yeah yeah so
you know one more one more round of
applause
okay now I'm sorry I'm gonna arrest all
of you
okay so um before we end I know you guys
um sent Super Chat so I'm going to read
them so mgtow by Logic my dad was trash
thus all men are trash makes perfect
sense for a unicorn to think top-notch
logic Pedro Domingo uh Church the chur
big brown she is at an absolutely
horrible human being big brown tell how
the medium attractive 304 on the far
left of the couch she isn't as
intelligent or attractive as she thinks
smash attention doesn't count we tell
all we tell all women we're beautiful to
smash zentians I'm a tiger ass a hoe who
who I'm a tiger ass a hoe who won't even
shut up let others talk when they have
given her that respect and is triggered
enough to not listen to others before
making assumptions that is exactly the
type of 304 that men don't want she
would give zero peace Pedro one of the
fundamental laws of humanity the law of
polarity and gender masculine feminine
and energy take any Modern Man and take
any modern women drop them in the middle
of the Jungle and watch the natural law
of survival take place Matt butcher we
are also damn privileged think about
what you're saying get out of your
bubble sum may be but are Are there
women fighting and dying in combat
dominating any heavy labor jobs no
appreciation as usual in the big picture
men and women need each other mgtow by
Logic how can a man be better than you
by paying for a date if you're equal to
him riddle me that then women in a
colorful shirt is clearly triggered as
she is using any and all rationalization
trying to twist any issues to the men's
fault as it was shown by the by by the
China's debate feminists are the simps
of the West they claim equality while
having ulterior motives mgtow by Logic
yeah a woman in Iran died and uh yeah a
woman in Iran died and lady you're not
doing anything about it the fact is who
cares what you say go there and fix it
if it's such a problem Matt butcher Zoo
beat please go to a compact Zone and
zubi please go to a combat zone and see
men taking responsibility that's as real
as it gets sentience men rule the world
you mean the fragment of all the top one
percent men that's a substrata of all
men you are falsely stating men rule the
world based on the exception just like
the exception of men who commit sa
majority of men don't have that
privilege
um Abraham I believe it was Jordan
Peterson that said you're using a small
portion of successful men to represent
the large majority ignoring all the men
who work on our infrastructure for crap
pay Sean Jackson woman fix it on the top
one percent of men that run most of the
world to justify their oppression
meanwhile most when men don't live like
meanwhile most men don't live like that
where most of us are considered worker
drones and you are an atn's ATMs for the
state match Matt butcher I don't know
who zooby is hanging out with but dang
dang dude men not taking responsibility
look around you look around you with a
different lens sir Joseph poor Nations
who do not have poor Nations do not have
the same issue with women in debt that
is because debt is the result of excess
when basic needs are not
are not met
accountability Reigns Supreme with two
Gain the issue appears
metabolic by Logic
what used to happen when a woman would
misspend her money provided to her men
had Authority now women demand Authority
but reject the responsibility while
complaining no men will pay for them
make it make sense Doug MPA King
Richie's is Right kids now have no
consequences so there is no respect for
their Elders teachers police anymore God
gotta say that Auntie is capping black
panther Pearl you cut off Alex midpoint
and then randomly gave the mic to a
chick who interrupted Alex then derailed
the entire conversation LOL DJ be fit
we're not evolving we're devolving women
recorded to have higher testosterone now
while men are recorded to have the
lowest testosterone in history Mark you
guys are defeated and it's sad you're
bending your will to the children
instead of bending theirs and to the
lady who was raised in poverty happy but
also says it's impossible and uses that
child as an excuse to unalive a child's
Madness they have principles Maurice let
them know auntie auntie is the only is
the only true African on the panel these
other Africans are mixed breeds mgtow by
Logic if any adult male hasn't been
assayed by a woman he's low value don't
at me DB debut I'm 47 and I've never
conceived a child out of wedlock wedlock
I played High School in University
American football women were easy to me
it's not hard to have to not have a baby
mama
um Christopher welcome to the episode of
female victim Olympics Auntie you would
be so disappointed uh Maurice
every woman that I have every woman that
I have met that has ever had an abortion
always said something died in them when
they actually committed it it's the
consequences of poor choices you made as
a woman deal with it Brett Cormier by by
some of the panel's logic Alexander
Hamilton would have never been born in
1755 if abortion was readily available
because he was born out of wedlock how
different would the U.S be today without
his influence zh zubi knows more about
the reproductive system than some of the
women on this panel he's referring to
the implantation which is when the egg
basically attaches to the uterus very
logical and consistent
um DJ befit how can you predict the
onboard child's trauma before birth that
kid could have been LeBron Jay-Z Halle
Berry we will never know because your
trauma is more important than the life
of the child Joseph metzer the brain is
developed by 12 Weeks the fetus fetus is
Latin for baby stop saying it's a baby
not a phoenix the morning after pill
stops the egg from implanting in the
womb
um
once
heat remedy purl's right key look at the
Galleon Institute this is Gates logic as
well
um robot once again Pearl and Andy prove
that modern women don't deserve
happiness nor understanding because if
you're willing to murder the most
defenseless life on the planet then the
question is she is mentally ill
um Okay so
thank you guys for the super chats thank
you for watching
um yes
um okay guys um thank you for watching
make sure you like the video on your way
out the like is the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these videos and these lives make sure
you leave a comment let us know what you
think who did you disagree with who is
your favorite guest your least favorite
guest
um any any comments any thoughts you can
put them in the comments
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
we're getting really close to 400k and I
really want to hit a half a million
before the end of the year
shout out Shout
out shout out to all of you um I I think
a year ago I had like 15 000 subscribers
so it's really crazy yeah
um don't forget to subscribe like the
video on your way out and we will talk
to you next time